Hey everybody! This is a super exciting episode. with Chip Morningstar. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is a super exciting episode. I actually was just on my Oculus yesterday. So I'm a big fan of virtual reality, the metaverse, augmented reality. I love all of this stuff. And I'm really excited to talk about it and dive in on the technical part, on the product
大家好！这是一集非常精彩的节目，嘉宾是奇普·莫宁星（Chip Morningstar）。交给你了，杰森。大家好。这是一集非常精彩的节目。其实我昨天刚用过Oculus。所以我非常喜欢虚拟现实、元宇宙、增强现实。我喜欢所有这些东西，而且我真的很兴奋能聊聊这个话题，深入探讨技术部分、产品部分，并全面解释虚拟现实的一切。非常感谢你能来节目，奇普。很高兴能来到这里。酷。那么首先，你最喜欢的虚拟现实体验是什么？首先，我得先说明一下，我其实对虚拟现实有点持怀疑态度，部分原因是我非常非常容易晕动症。所以你只要把我放进那些Oculus头显里，我大概只能坚持两分钟，就会一把扯下设备，趴在地板上恶心想吐，基本上就彻底废了。所以，真正让我感到惊艳的是Tilt Five。我不知道那是什么，你得解释一下。好的，Tilt Five是一位名叫杰里·埃尔斯沃思（Jeri Ellsworth）的女性发明的。她在为Valve从事VR工作时发现了一些现象，现在已经历了硅谷风险投资冒险的常规考验，并走到了另一头。他们的做法不是试图把你放进一个沉浸式体验中，而是给你配备了一套带有视频投影仪的眼镜。它们字面意思就是小型视频投影仪，然后你通过一个逆反射表面来观看，它们会在你面前将画面渲染出来，就好像你在物理世界中看着任何你实际会看到的3D环境一样，而且它真的管用。它有效地与你周围的物理世界同步了，而且不会让我感到晕动症。所以我非常喜欢它。多年来我一直是杰里的超级粉丝，我强烈建议大家去了解一下。哇。太酷了。所以我昨天在做的事情，已经成了我的日常，就是我戴上了腕重。它们有一个拇指扣和一个魔术贴带子。所以它缠在你的手腕上，增加了那里的重量。然后我有Oculus控制器，戴着腕重，还戴着头显，我在打拳击。所以我试图在手腕上增加越来越重的重量，然后看看我还能不能在困难模式下通关这个VR拳击游戏。这其实真的非常有满足感，真的很爽。在VR中挨揍其实真的挺烦人的，它已经达到了那种程度，就是当你被VR击倒时，你会有一种发自内心的感觉，尽管你实际上根本没动。好吧，我的意思是，我们接下来可能会看到各种触觉接口的很多创新。不过，那种能在拳击比赛中让你挨揍的设备，你可以想象，这可能会引发很多问题。
part, and just explain everything VR. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Chip. I'm happy to be here. Cool. So just to get it going, what has been your favorite virtual reality experience? First of all, I should preface things by saying I'm a little bit of a virtual reality skeptic, in part because I'm terribly, terribly prone to motion sickness. And so you put me in one of those Oculus headsets, and I can last about two minutes before I'm just tearing the thing off and rolling on the floor in nausea, and damn, pretty much shot. So no, the thing that has really
哦，是的，我懂。我觉得这不是个好主意。事实上，VR拳击教会我的一点是，除了锻炼和有氧运动之外，它还让我明白我真的不想卷入打架。我想我大概从七岁左右开始，就再也没有经历过任何形式的身体冲突了。但这只会强化这样一种观点：卷入街头斗殴之类的绝对是糟透了。这倒不是一个坏教训。我还有VR国际象棋。所以曾有一段时间我在玩国际象棋拳击，我会把VR拳击和VR国际象棋交替着玩。我觉得自己非常……
impressed the hell out of me is tilt five i don't know what that is you have to explain it okay so tilt five was a creation of a woman named jerry ellsworth who discovered some phenomena when she was working on vr for valve and has now has since gone through the usual gauntlet of Silicon Valley venture capital adventures and things and come out the other end. What they do is rather than attempting to put you in a immersive experience, they have a set of glasses
那是一种奇怪的……我不知道你该不该把它叫做一项运动，但它是那种我会跟别人提起，只为了看他们露出难以置信表情的事情之一。是的，同样地，我觉得我不介意下棋的部分，但我真的不想脸部挨拳头。所以现实生活中的国际象棋拳击是不行了，但VR国际象棋拳击其实挺有趣的。另一个我认为非常有趣的VR项目是Mojo Vision，这是一家由我的另一位老相识创立的公司。他们的产品是隐形眼镜中的高分辨率视频显示屏。哦，哇。以及各种传感器技术，以确保它能正确追踪你的眼睛和头部运动，诸如此类。而且，这更像是一个增强现实项目，他们可以将来自真实世界的视觉通道与来自显示器的视觉通道叠加在一起。他们对人类视觉系统做了一些非常有趣生物物理模型研究，使得分辨率能够适应你的视网膜。所以你能获得非常高分辨率的体验。我其实还没鼓起勇气把隐形眼镜戴在眼球上，所以我对这方面的了解大多是理论上的，但那些玩过它的人都印象深刻。太酷了。好的，这是一个很好的切入点。那么，我们何不稍微退一步，奇普，跟我们讲讲你的背景，你一直在做什么，以及是什么促成了你现在在Agoric的现状？
that have video projectors on them. And they're literally small video projectors, which you then view through a retro reflective surface and which they then render in front of you as if you were looking at whatever 3d environment that you would actually be looking at in the physical world and it actually works it is effectively synced to physical world around you and it doesn't make me motion sick. So I love it. And I've been a big fan of Jerry's for years and years and years and years. And I totally recommend checking it out. Wow. Super cool. So what I was doing yesterday, which has become a routine for me is I actually put on, I have wrist weights. So they actually have a thumb
你的故事是怎样的？是的，我想问题在于你有多想深入了解我的个人传记。有趣的是，我最初是一名航空航天工程专业的学生，我想设计宇宙飞船。但经过我在密歇根大学的第一年学习后，我非常失望地发现，当你成为一名航空航天工程专业时，你并不能设计宇宙飞船。你设计的是，你知道的，从左边数第三个机翼支柱。但在实现这种太空愿景的过程中，通过家庭关系、朋友和胆识的结合，我设法在密歇根大学空间物理研究实验室（Space Physics Research Laboratory）找到了一份暑期工作，该实验室当时在密歇根大学从事太空相关的工作。我当时，你知道的，这是一种半工半读的学生工作，我基本上是个跑腿的。我为一个电气工程师工作，他设计用于卫星和气球任务的地勤支援设备。而且，你知道的，我经常拿着图纸跑到绘图部门去更新，因为当时就是那样做的，你知道的，还要归档产品文献，做一些跑腿的杂活。他们订购了一台PDP——数字设备公司（Digital Equipment Corporation）的PDP-11/34计算机，作为代号为BOSS的项目地勤支援设备。
loophole and it has a Velcro strap. And so it goes around your wrist and adds weight there. And then I actually have the Oculus controllers, I have the wrist weights, and then I have the headset on, I do boxing. And so I've tried to add more and more like heavier and heavier weights on my wrists and then see if i can still beat this uh boxing game on hard and it's uh it's actually really really satisfying it's uh it's really fun getting punched in vr actually really bothers me it's getting to that point where like yeah like you just feel this visceral feeling when you get knocked out in VR, even though you haven't moved. Well, I mean, I think we're probably going to be seeing a lot of innovation in haptic interfaces of various kinds. Although the one that lets you get slugged in a boxing match may, you know, I can imagine there being a lot of issues with that.
这个项目叫做平流层物种气球观测（Balloon Observation of Stratospheric Species），他们会将一个气球载荷带到平流层非常非常高的空中，比如10万英尺或更高，然后将其从气球上投掷下来。当它穿过大气层急速下坠时，它有一系列突出的吊舱，看起来像喷气发动机，里面装有气相色谱仪。你最终得到的基本上是该点大气层的核心样本。
Oh, yeah, I know. I don't think it's a good idea. Actually, the VR boxing has taught me, beyond just workout and cardio, it's also taught me that I really don't want to be in a fight. I don't think I've ever been in any kind of physical thing since I was, I don't know, seven years old or something. But it just reinforces that being in a street fight or something would be absolutely terrible. That's not a bad lesson to learn. I also have chess for the VR. And so there was a period of time where I was doing chess boxing, where I'd alternate from boxing, VR boxing to VR chess. I felt very...
然后在接近地面时，降落伞会弹出来（希望如此），然后它会平稳着陆。为了配合这个项目，他们拥有了这台PDP-11。但这种设备的交付周期可能只有几周，也可能是六到八个月，因为这非常难以预测。因此，他们在实际需要它之前的几个月就订购了这台计算机。正如运气所眷顾的那样，它提前到了。所以他们所做的就是把它插上电源以确保它能正常工作。他们把它放在办公室的一个后角，而那个后角碰巧就是把我塞进去的那个办公室的后角。整个夏天，我和PDP-11都在那里，我没有太多事情可做，但那里有一大堆手册。我开始摆弄它，阅读手册，然后说，哦，这东西是干什么的？到了夏天结束时，我觉得，玩这个东西比我想象的还要有趣。我只是上了工程学专业要求每个人都修读的第一批编程课程，作为基础核心技能，并且很喜欢它，于是我决定，我觉得我更想做这个。我把专业转成了计算机工程。这把我带入了软件的世界。哇，太疯狂了。
That's a strange, I don't know if you want to call it a sport, but it's one of those things that I tell people about just to watch the look of disbelief. Yeah, again, I feel like I don't mind the chess part, but I really don't want to get punched in the face. So real life chess boxing is out, but VR chess boxing is actually quite fun. The other VR thing, which I think is really interesting, is Mojo Vision, which is a company founded by another longtime acquaintance. And their thing is a high resolution video display in a contact lens. Oh, wow. Along with various sensor technology to make sure it tracks your eye properly and your head movements properly and all of that. And once
所以我觉得这里有一个非常好的重点，那就是你当时和这台计算机以及这堆手册实际呆在一起。这看起来可能非常有压倒性。很多人看到这一堆东西可能会说，好吧，我怎么可能读得完这一堆手册？甚至有人可能会说，好吧，这台计算机，如果我把它弄坏了，下一台可能需要八个月才能送到，他们可能会因此而感到害怕。所以我认为你采取了勇敢的一步，说不，我要学会这个，我要……你知道的，去承担这个风险，而且这得到了回报。是的，好吧，同时——我也有一位非常支持我的老板，他只是（你知道的）非常高兴地鼓励我去探索和摆弄各种东西。
again, it's more of an augmented reality thing where they can overlay the visual channel from the real world onto the visual channel from the display. And they've done some really interesting biophysical model of the human vision system stuff so that the resolution is adapted to your retina. And so you get a very high resolution thing. I haven't actually had the nerve to put a contact lens on my eye yet. So most of my knowledge of this is theoretical, but the people who played with it are very impressed. Super cool. Okay, so that's kind of a good lead in. So why don't we step back a little bit and why don't you tell us, Chip, about your kind of background, what you've been up to and what kind of led you to be where you are now at Agoric.
而且，你知道的，就像是“不，你不会通过在键盘上输入命令来把电脑弄坏的”。而且我们习惯了事情既复杂又技术性，并且需要阅读大量的文档。我认为那时的文档比现在更常见。现在，我感觉人们更加急躁了，特别是在开始接触某事方面。其中有一件事，这实际上与我职业生涯的其他故事相吻合。在密歇根大学，我和安娜堡计算俱乐部（Ann Arbor Computing Club）的一群人混在了一起，其中包括“仙那度计划”（Project Xanadu）的一些初始成员。仙那度是最初的超文本项目之一。事实上，它是由特德·尼尔森（Ted Nelson）创立的，他正是创造“超文本”这个词的人。他们对这个全球范围内的项目有着宏大的愿景，
What's kind of your story? Yeah, I guess the question is how much biographical depth you care to go into there. What's interesting, I started out in aerospace engineering as a student, and I wanted to design spaceships and discovered, much to my disappointment, over the first year I had in school at the University of Michigan, that when you're an aerospace engineer, you don't get to design spaceships. You get to design like, you know, the third wing strut from the left. But in service of this sort of space vision, I managed through a combination of family connections and friends and audacity to get a summer job at the
这个东西看起来非常像万维网（World Wide Web），只不过我认为他们的愿景在实际运作中比万维网还要好。好吧，我的意思是，这就是关键所在：在你的想象中，事情总是比现实中运转得更好。他曾是SRI（斯坦福研究所）的一名研究员，曾做过一个名为Augment的系统，这是最早的超文本系统之一。他做过一个非常著名的演示，我想那是在一个ARPA会议上还是什么的。你可以在YouTube上找到它的视频，
University of Michigan Space Physics Research Laboratory, which was doing space stuff at U of M. And I was, you know, this is a sort of first part-time student job thing. I was basically a gopher. I worked for an electrical engineer who designed ground support equipment for satellite and balloon missions. And, you know, I did a lot of running drawings down to the drafting department to get updated. And because that was done in those days and, you know, filing product literature and keeping, literature and keeping basically gopher stuff. And they had ordered a PDP, a Digital Equipment Corporation PDP-1134 computer as a ground support equipment for a project called BOSS,
行业里的许多人将这个演示称为“所有演示之母”。这是引发许多事情的开创性事件之一，它开阔了人们的眼界，让人看到了各种可能性。道格的核心论点之一是，你想要做的是用计算机来增强人类的能力。他不介意你在开始时有一点学习曲线，因为你在学习如何使用这个工具上会有所投入，你可能需要花上几周时间来真正精通它，而不是期望自己能够坐下来，
which is the Balloon Observation of Stratospheric Species, which was they would take a balloon package that they would take high, high up into the stratosphere, like 100,000 feet or more, and then drop it off of the balloon. And as it plunged down through the atmosphere, it had a series of pods that stuck out of it that couldn't look like jet engines that contained gas chromatographs. And what you'd get was essentially a core sample of the atmosphere at that point.
立刻上手并开始使用。因为你花了几周时间学习某些东西，但接下来你将在余生中使用这个工具。所以，支付前期的学习成本是完全可以接受的。而现在，我们更加急躁，我们在起点上更期望即时满足，尽管事实上，经验已经告诉我们，人们确实需要几周甚至几年的时间才能真正掌握许多这类工具。我们看看像Adobe Photoshop或任何这类3D建模和编辑程序，要真正精通它们确实需要几个月、几年甚至数年时间。是的，这说得通。
And then close to the ground, a parachute would pop out, hopefully, and then it would make a soft landing. And in support of this, they had this PDP-11, but the lead times for delivery of that kind of equipment could have been a couple of weeks or it could have been six or eight months because it was highly unpredictable. And so they ordered the computer months in advance of their actual need for it. And as fortune would have it, it arrived early. And so what they did is they plugged it in to make sure it worked. And they set it up in the back corner of an office, which happened to be
这里有几个背景信息。所以SRI是——如果我没记错的话——斯坦福研究所（Stanford Research Institute），对吧？它确实是斯坦福研究所，当他们在60年代末、70年代初作为剥离与国防部有联系的许多研究机构的一部分从斯坦福分拆出来时，他们将其更名为SRI。哦，我不知道这一点。真有趣。当我还是一名学生的时候，我在一个叫密歇根环境研究所（Environmental Research Institute of Michigan, ERIM）的实验室工作过。那也是从密歇根大学分拆出来的。它曾经是密歇根大学的威洛朗实验室（Willow Run Laboratories）。在70年代初，由于反战抗议活动，它被分拆了出去，因为它的许多资金也来自国防部。那是当时的道德恐慌。我认为有许多机构都经历过这种转变。明白了。所以你把专业改成了计算机工程并完成了学业。那么你大学毕业后的第一份工作是什么，你的第一份计算机工程工作？是的，这取决于你想了解多少细节。再次说明，我的第一份工作就是空间物理实验室的那份工作，我逐渐在那里（你知道的）承担了更多的责任，并（正如我所说的那样）做了更多实际的动手技术工作。我们当时从事的许多工程都是用于支持各种航天项目的地勤支援设备。有很多硬件原型设计。在某些情况下，甚至连原型设计都算不上，我们只是在实际制造硬件，它不一定是航天硬件，而是用于支持航天硬件的地勤支援设备。所以其中很多工作都是通过绕线板（wire-wrap prototyping boards）完成的。密歇根大学的分时系统上运行着一个名为WireApp的实用程序，你可以通过它指定——你基本上将你的电路原理图转换成宏语言，说明你正在使用以下的门电路、芯片和其他东西。其中有一些宏编码了芯片的几何形状，哪些引脚连接到哪些输入和输出。然后你用这种文本宏语言指定该设备的逻辑连接。
the back corner of the same office that they had me stashed in. And it was me and the PDP-11 for the summer with me without a lot to do, but there was a big stack of manuals. And I started playing around with it and reading the manuals and saying, oh, what does this thing do? And by the end of the summer, I was like, I'm having more fun playing with this thing. And I had taken sort of, you know, the first programming courses that they put everyone in engineering through as just sort of basic core skills, and had enjoyed that and decided, you know, I think I'd rather do this. And I changed my major to computer engineering. And that launched me into the world of software. Wow, that's wild.
然后你通过WireApp程序运行它，它会吐出各种结果WireApp板的图纸，外加供技术人员将板子连线、将芯片插在什么地方以及将哪些引脚连接到其他哪些引脚的说明，或者实际上生成磁带或卡片组来驱动自动绕线机，以实际组装或制造你心中构想的设备。我成了负责维护这个程序的人。随着他们制作的原型板的几何形状变得越来越灵活和复杂，他们需要对此程序进行许多相当复杂的添加，而我接管了这件东西的维护工作，这是一个庞大的IBM 370汇编语言软件。但幸运的是，这是编写得非常好、结构非常清晰的IBM 370汇编语言软件。我从研究这段代码中学到了很多东西，最终对它进行了大量的扩充。
So I think there's kind of a really good point there, which is you were kind of there physically with this computer and this stack of manuals. And that could look really overwhelming. A lot of people could look at that and say, well, how am I going to read through a stack of manuals? Or even people might say, well, this computer, if I break this, the next one could take eight months to arrive and they could be afraid for that reason. And so I think you kind of took the bold step to say, no, I'm going to learn this i'm going to uh uh you know take my chance with that and and it paid off yeah well also i mean i had a very supportive boss who was was just you know very happy to encourage me to explore and to fiddle with things and and
我被我之前提到的另一个实体——ERIM（密歇根环境研究所）联系了，他们也使用WireApp程序进行硬件原型设计，并且他们想要对其进行一些更复杂的处理。他们说：“嘿，你为什么不来为我们工作呢？我们可以付给你多得多的钱。”当时我在空间物理实验室基本上拿的是最低工资。请注意，我当时在大学里大约是个软件专业大三的学生。而且，你知道的，他们主动提出把我的收入翻倍，从大约每小时1.80美元提高到每小时3.60美元左右，这对我当时来说，那是我们现在所称的激光雷达（LiDAR）的早期版本。
you know and and it's like no you you're not going to break the computer by typing commands on the keyboard and and we're used to things being complicated and technical and having a bunch of documentation you had to read that was, I think, more normal then than it is now. Today, we have, I think, more impatience, particularly with respect to getting started with something. One of the things, this actually dovetails with other stories about my career. At the University of Michigan, I fell in with a group at the Ann Arbor Computing Club, who included a bunch of the initial people at Project Xanadu. Xanadu was one of the sort of the original hypertext projects. In fact, it was founded by Ted Nelson, who is the person who actually coined the term hypertext. And they had this whole vision for this worldwide,
我们称之为飞点扫描激光传感器（Flying Spot Scanning Laser Sensor）之类的东西。本质上，它是对激光测距仪进行光栅扫描。你得到的这些图像是深度图像，而不是光学反射率图像。然后我们有一个叫做CytoComputer的东西，这是一个在ERIM开发的大规模流水线并行图像处理机器。我学会了对它进行编程，最后实际上为进行图像处理开发了一种编程语言。
this thing that looked very much like the World Wide Web, except that I think their vision, it worked better than the World Wide Web actually works. Well, I mean, that's the thing is in your imagination, things always work better than they do in reality. who was a researcher at SRI who had done a system called Augment that was one of the very first hypertech systems. And there's a very famous demo that he gave, I think it was an ARPA conference or something. There's a video of it you can find on YouTube,
所以，你是怎么从那里去到卢卡斯影业（Lucasfilm）的？啊，事情是这样的，ERIM通常每年会派你参加一个主要会议。作为一名工程师，我在1980、1981、1982年参加了在阿纳海姆举办的全国计算机会议（National Computer Conference）。我想那大概是1981年吧。我不记得具体年份了。这不重要。我的一个好朋友，实际上是我婚礼上的伴郎，
which is referred to by a lot of people in the industry as sort of the mother of all demos. It's one of these sort of seminal events that kicked off a lot of stuff, kind of opening people's eyes as to the possibilities. And one of Doug's theses was that what you wanted to do was augment people's capabilities with computers. And he didn't mind if you had a little bit of a learning curve at the beginning because you'd have an investment in learning how to use this tool, there where you might have to take, you know, a few weeks to actually master something as opposed to expecting that you should be able to just sit down and
去雅达利（Atari）工作了。雅达利与卢卡斯影业有一个联合项目来制作游戏。正当我准备飞往NCC时，我在电话里跟我的朋友汤姆聊天，他说，嗯，我要飞往旧金山去参观卢卡斯影业。当时，我的家人住在加利福尼亚州内华达山脉的高地。我家族的生意是位于高地的一家小型湖畔山间度假村。这对我的道德和智力发展也很有影响。
immediately jump in and start using it. Because you spend a few weeks learning something, but then you're going to use this tool for the rest of your life. And so, you know, paying the upfront learning cost was fine. And nowadays, we're much more impatient, we're much more expecting sort of immediate gratification at the starting point, even though in fact, experience has taught us that it really does take weeks or years even for people to really acquire mastery of a lot of these tools. We look at something like Adobe Photoshop or any of these 3D modeling and editing programs, and they really do take months and months and years and years to become truly skilled at them. Yeah, that makes sense.
但不管怎样，我想，其实我可以更改航班计划，飞往旧金山。我可以顺便跟着汤姆去参观卢卡斯影业。然后我们可以上去看望我的家人，接着开车去阿纳海姆，而这正是我们最后做的事情。所以我真的这么做了，就像个跟屁虫一样跟着去了。我得以参观了卢卡斯影业的办公室，并在参观时结识了那里的一些人。我的意思是，我们基本上就是（你知道的）技术游客。但那里真的很棒。我的意思是，他们有VAX计算机。
So a couple of background pieces there. So SRI is, and correct me if I'm wrong, Stanford Research Institute, right? It was the Stanford Research Institute, and they rebranded it as SRI when they got spun off from Stanford as part of the divestiture from universities of a lot of research institutions that had ties to the Department of Defense back in the late 60s, early 70s. Oh, I didn't know that. Interesting. I worked at a lab back when I was a student called the Environmental Research Institute of Michigan, ERIM. And that was also a spinoff from the University of Michigan. It used to be the Willow Run Laboratories of the University of Michigan. And it got spun off back in the early
他们有Fax（传真）？是VAX。VAX计算机。哦，Fax。哦，对，那个时代的主流计算机。对，对。你不能直接去商店买一台，你知道的，因为它的价格是你年薪的20倍。
70s as a result of anti-war protests, because a lot of their funding came from the Department of Defense as well. And that was the moral panic at the time. I think a number of institutions that kind of went through that transition. Got it. So you changed your major to computer engineering and you went through and got that. And then what was your first job out of college, your first computer engineering job? Yeah, it depends on how much details you want to go into. Once again, my first job was this job at the Space Physics Lab where I sort of gradually, you know, took on more responsibility and, you know, did more actual hands-on technical things as I said, a lot of the engineering we were working on was ground support equipment for support of various spaceflight projects. And there's a lot of hardware prototyping. And in some cases, not even prototyping, we're just actually building hardware, and it wasn't necessarily spaceflight hardware, it was ground support equipment in support of spaceflight hardware. And so a lot
他们拥有高分辨率的图形显示器，并且在做着非常酷的事情。我离开时就觉得，哇，那会是一个很酷的工作地点。这有点算是题外话，但我只是想在这里插话一会儿。我曾问过某人为什么——我对硬件技术其实不太在行。我确实有一个Oculus，但公平地说，我是因为做了一些工作才免费得到的。所以我大概不会自己去买一个。我也不是那种拥有大显示器之类设备的人。但我的办公桌上有两个大显示器，它们从来没真正开过机。
of it was done with wire app prototyping boards. And there was a utility called wire app that ran on the University of Michigan time sharing system, where you would specify you basically you transcribe your circuit schematic into a macro language that said you're using the following gates and chips and other things. There were macros that encoded the geometry of the chips, which pins were connected to which inputs and which outputs. And then you would specify the logical connectivity of this device in this textual macro language.
你知道的，有一次我问为什么，甚至有些根本没人坐的办公桌上也摆着这么大的显示器。我问他们，为什么后勤部门要在所有的办公桌上都放上巨大的显示器？有人告诉我的一件事非常有趣，他们说，因为当候选人来这里面试时，看到所有这些巨大且昂贵的显示器，他们会觉得，哦，这些人拥有很酷的设备，这一定是一个非常酷的工作地点。我以前完全没有从这个角度想过，直到有人说出来，这感觉有点像看到米老鼠摘下了面具一样。
And then you run it through the wire app program and it would spit out variously diagrams of the wire app board that would result, plus instructions for a technician to wire up the board and where to plug the chips in and what pins to connect to what other pins, or actually produce a tape or a card deck to drive an automated wire wrapping machine to actually assemble or fabricate the device that you had in mind. And I became the person responsible for maintaining this. And they had a bunch of fairly complicated additions to this program that they needed as the geometry of the prototyping boards that they were having got more flexible and more sophisticated. And I took over maintenance of this thing, which was this enormous piece of IBM 370 assembly language software. But unfortunately, it was really well written, really well structured IBM 370 assembly language software. And I learned a lot from studying this code and then ended up augmenting it at length.
就像面具摘了下来，你会觉得：“哦，天哪，这才是真正的重点。”但我认为这里面有很多真实之处。好吧，我的意思是，当然了，纯粹的技术渴望。卢卡斯影业的办公室绝对激发了这一点，尽管那里还有地毯、木制品、黄铜，以及挂在墙上的星球大战原始前期制作艺术品，还有很多其他公司办公室所没有的东西。真棒。我听说雅达利（Atari）的办公室非常疯狂。我听过各种各样的故事。我不知道哪些是真的，所以我不想说出来，但我确实听说过。
And I got contacted by this other entity I mentioned, the ERIM, the Environmental Research Institute of Michigan, who were also doing prototyping of hardware using the WireApp program, and they had some even more sophisticated things that they wanted to do to it. They said, well, why don't you come work for us? We can pay you much more, which was, you know, I was essentially earning minimum wage at the Space Physics Lab. Mind you, I'm like at this point, I'm like a software junior in college. And, you know, they offered to like double my income from like, you know, $1.80 an hour to $3.60 an hour or something like that, which to me at the time, what was early versions of what we now call LiDAR.
好吧，当然了，在我最终去卢卡斯影业工作时，事情是这样的：我想那是1983年夏天的SIGGRAPH会议，地点在底特律，所以大概是我去参观他们的82年。比尔·里夫斯（Bill Reeves）是卢卡斯影业的图形技术人员之一，他写了一篇关于粒子系统的论文。那是具有开创性的粒子系统论文。我当时被这有多酷震撼到了，因为这是我在计算机图形学中看到的第一样东西。
We called it the Flying Spot Scanning Laser Sensor or something like that. Essentially, it was raster scanning a laser range finder. You get these images, which were depth images rather than optical reflectance images. And then we had a thing called the CytoComputer, which was a massively pipelined parallel image processing machine that had been developed at ERIM that I learned to program and then ended up actually developing a programming language for doing image processing.
它不仅仅是关于绘制多边形，而是关于创造图像。我想，哇，这些家伙真的搞懂了，他们触及了一些重要的东西。所以，我只是碰运气把简历寄给了他们，因为他们的地址写在那篇SIGGRAPH论文的版权页上。我只是把简历寄了过去。
So, yeah, how did you get from there to lucasfilm then ah well so what happened was iram would send you to like one major conference a year as an engineer and i went to the national computer conference in anaheim in 1980, 81, 82. I guess it was probably 1981. I don't know. I don't remember the year. It doesn't matter. So one of my best friends, actually the best man at my wedding,
这有点像买彩票，你花两块钱买一张彩票，然后开始梦想如果你中了一亿美元会发生什么。而在这种情况下，邮资是两毛五分钱，你可以开始梦想：如果你能为这家很酷的公司做这些很酷的事情，那会是什么感觉？
had gone to work for Atari. And Atari had a sort of joint venture project with Lucasfilm to do games. And as I was getting ready to fly out to NCC, I was talking to my friend Tom on the phone, and he said, well, I'm going to fly into San Francisco and go visit Lucasfilm. And at the time, my family lived in the High Sierra in Nevada, California. My family's business was a small lakeside mountain resort up in the High Sierras. Also very influential on my, let's say, moral and intellectual development.
然后到了秋天，我之前提到过的仙那度（Xanadu）确实获得了一些资金，其中一部分用于将他们从安娜堡搬到西海岸，让他们离核心圈子更近一些。我们正准备打包行李，距离AT&T的人来给我们断电话仅剩半小时左右（这也是当年常见的事），这时我的电话响了，是卢卡斯影业的彼得·兰斯顿（Peter Langston）打来的。他说：“请问是奇普·莫宁星吗？”我说：“是的，我是。”然后他说：“我是卢卡斯影业的彼得·兰斯顿。”我当时想：“哇，你为什么给我打电话？”原来是这样的：他们收到了
But be that as it may, I thought, well, actually, I could change my flight plans to fly into San Francisco. And I can tag along with Tom while we visit Lucasfilm. And then we can go up, visit my family, and then drive down to Anaheim, which is what we ended up doing. And so I did that and just kind of tagged along. And I got to see the Lucasfilm offices and get to meet with some of the people there as we were doing it. I mean, we were just basically being, you know, technology tourists. But it was really, really nice. I mean, they had vaxes.
我的简历，有人看了一眼并说：“这或许是我们想聊聊的人。”我不知道。但后来他把简历弄丢了。他因为弄丢了简历而要受到人力资源的责备。所以他说：“你能再发给我一份吗？”
They had faxes? Vaxes. The vax. Oh, fax. Oh, yeah. The computer of that era. Right, right. You could just go down to the store and buy one, you know, because it costs, you it costs 20 times what your annual salary would be.
我说：“我很乐意，但我正在搬家。”他说：“等你安顿好了给我们打个电话。”当然，在那之后，他们不得不邀请我去面试。所以我的结论是：在卢卡斯影业获得录用的方法是拥有一个容易记住的名字，这样他们就能在查号台找到你，然后让他们把你的文书工作弄丢。曾经有一段时间，我们以为我们应该随机粉碎一半的简历，这样我们雇佣的所有人都很幸运。是的。
And they had these high-resolution graphics displays, and they were doing this really cool stuff. And I just kind of went away from that saying, wow, that would be a cool place to work. This is a bit of a segue, but I just wanted to interject here for a moment. I asked somebody why – so I'm kind of not that good with hardware technology. I do have an Oculus, but to be fair, I got it for free because of some work I was doing. So I don't think I would have had one otherwise. And I'm just not like a person who has like, you know, big monitors or anything like that. But my desk had these two large monitors and they were never really on.
所以也许你就是那些幸运儿之一。是的。我可不想雇佣运气不好的人。也许他们所谓的“弄丢了简历”这其实是拉里·尼文（Larry Niven）的一些“已知空间”系列小说中的情节，他假定在未来为了限制人口增长，他们有权让孩子成为抽签的结果。现在，经过几代人的繁衍，他们选育出了一群具有基因天赋的好运的人。太棒了。
You know, at one point I kind of asked why, you know, even there were desks that nobody was sitting in that had these huge monitors. And I asked them, why does the facilities folks just put huge monitors on all the tasks? And what somebody told me, which is really interesting, they said, because when candidates come to interview here and they see all these huge, expensive monitors, they feel like, oh, these people have cool equipment and it must be a really cool place to work. And I had not thought of it that way at all until when someone, it's almost like seeing Mickey Mouse without their mask on or something.
所以你是通过那份简历加入了卢卡斯影业。然后你被分配去从事……其实，在我们谈论这个之前，你先讲讲什么是Habitat，或者Habitat是什么？好吧，Habitat是一个项目……其实，这确实与卢卡斯影业的性质有点关系，
Like the mask comes off and you're like, oh my gosh, this is really what it's about. But I think there's a lot of truth to that, I think. Well, I mean, certainly that, I mean, sort of pure technology lust. The Lucasfilm offices definitely inspired that, although there was also, you know, the carpet and the woodwork and the brass and the, you know, original Star Wars pre-production artwork hanging on the walls and a lot of other things that, that other companies offices don't have. Nice. I heard that Atari offices were wild. Like I've heard all sorts of stories. I don't know which ones are true, so I don't want to say any of them, but I've heard.
那就是我最后应聘加入了卢卡斯影业游戏部（Lucasfilm Games），它并不是负责制作炫酷计算机图形的图形小组。他们后来被分拆成另一家公司，也就是我们现在所知的皮克斯（Pixar）。而且他们转了一圈又被重新收购了，这挺酷的。是的，现在它们都归迪士尼所有，对吧？它们现在都归迪士尼所有。
Well, certainly at, at well, when I, when I actually ended up going to work for, for Lucasfilm, what happened was the Sraph conference in i guess it would have been the summer of 1983 was in detroit so i guess it was 82 when i when i visited them um and bill reeves who was one of the graphics guys at lucasfilm had done this paper on particle systems. And it was sort of the seminal particle systems paper. And I was just overwhelmed at how cool this was because it was the first thing I'd seen in computer graphics.
当时卢卡斯影业拥有所有这些极具创新性的研究小组，为电影和娱乐相关的技术从事先进的技术开发，其中之一就是计算机图形小组。他们有一个数字音频小组，其中一些人做了最早的音频信号处理工作。他们还有一个游戏小组，这基本上是因为雅达利给了他们一笔资金来开展这项工作。但后来，当他们经历了一些公司演变、决定需要将这些业务剥离出去，因为它们过于昂贵且分散精力时，
It wasn't just about drawing polygons. It was about making images. And I thought, wow, these, these, these guys have really got it dialed in there. They're on onto something significant here. And so just on a flyer, I sent them my resume because their address was in the colophon of the SIGGRAPH paper. And I just sent them my resume.
他们保留了游戏小组，因为它实际上是在生产娱乐产品而不是技术。乔治给我们的宪章是——我对此记忆犹新，因为我们开了一场令人难忘的会议——他说：“你们的使命是保持规模小、做到最好、不要亏钱。”所以我们基本上拥有完全的自由去做任何我们想做的事，只要有别人为此买单。事实证明这并不算太难，因为许多人都想沾一沾《星球大战》反射出的光辉，并带着资金来找我们做事情。
And it's kind of like entering the lottery where you pay two bucks for your lottery ticket and you get to dream about what would happen if you won $100 million. And in this case, it was 25 cents for postage and you get to dream about, well, what would it be like if you got to work for this cool company doing this cool stuff?
有一年，一个名叫克莱夫·史密斯（Clive Smith）的人来找我们，他是康莫多国际公司（Commodore International）的战略规划副总裁。他们那一年承担了几项战略举措。其中之一是收购了Amiga，另一项是对……的巨额投资。因此，每年他们都会在圣诞季推出一个新玩意儿来搭配你的Commodore 64，而今年将是一个非常便宜的1200波特调制解调器。作为其中的一部分，他们对一家名为QuantumLink的公司进行了战略投资，这是一家专门面向Commodore 64用户的在线服务公司。这是最早的——
And then in the fall, Xanadu, which I mentioned previously, had actually gotten some funding, part of which was to move them from Ann Arbor to the West Coast, where they'd be closer to where the action was. We were getting ready to pack up our house and we're literally like a half hour from having the guy from AT&T come and disconnect our phone which was also a thing back in those days when my phone rang and it was Peter Langston from Lucasfilm and he said is this Chip Morningstar and I said well yes it is and and he said well this is this is Peter Likes it from Lucasfilm. And I was like, whoa, why are you calling me? What had happened was they had gotten
我认为是第一批真正以消费者为导向的服务之一，当时这些在线服务按使用小时收费，而且相当昂贵。CompuServe每小时收费8到20美元。在这种环境下，他们提供的服务是每小时3美元。部分原因在于他们只在晚间和周末开放，购买了主要与商业客户打交道的商业X.25网络的闲置网络带宽容量。然后他们做了一些非常创新的事情，因为这一切都是针对Commodore 64客户端的，他们可以制作一个定制客户端，优化带宽的使用，进行各种生动的互动，并提供一种更容易接近的、面向消费者的服务。
my resume and somebody had looked at it and said, maybe this is somebody we want to talk to. I don't know. But then he had lost it. And he was going to get in trouble with HR because he'd lost his resume. And so he said, could you send
他们对能够使用这种在线服务的游戏很感兴趣，当然了，卢卡斯影业嘛，嘿，让我们让他们参与进来。于是他们找到我们，问我们能为他们做些什么。当时，游戏小组里的任何人有了想法，他们都会写下两三页的想法摘要。然后，（你知道的）它会在小组内部传阅并讨论，最终进入我们总经理文件柜里的一个文件夹中。管理日常事务的史蒂夫·阿诺德（Steve Arnold）会保留这份潜在项目的库存。然后当有人来洽谈时，他会大致评估他们对什么感兴趣，并从文件柜里抽出这些东西说：“嘿，我们有这些。”当时我和我当时的办公室伙伴诺亚·法尔斯坦（Noah Falstein）一起构思了一个点子，我们称之为“卢卡斯影业宇宙”（Lucasfilms Universe），当时我们开始争论关于游戏的“人工智能”。等等，诺亚是《猴岛的秘密》（The Secret of Monkey Island）的那个诺亚吗？
me another one? And I said, I'd be happy to, but I'm still moving. He said, well, give us a call when you get in. And of course, after that, they had to have me up for an interview. And so I say, the way you would get hired at Lucasfilm was to have a memorable name so that they could find you in directory assistance and then have them lose your paperwork. There is this, there was this time where we thought we would randomly shred half of the resumes so that all the people we hire are lucky. That's yes.
不，那是罗恩·吉尔伯特（Ron Gilbert）。哦。不，我认为也参与了《猴岛》。我们所有人都参与了所有这些项目。但《猴岛》主要是罗恩的作品。我可以给你讲讲一些故事。不管怎样，我们在吃午饭时就这个话题争论过，我说：“好吧，我不知道如何创造一个在互动性上能够像真人一样丰富且微妙的人工智能。但我们为什么不直接把你连接到另一个真人呢？”这就催生了一个关于这个多人开放宇宙项目的模糊提议。从最初的描述来看，它可能更类似于——我想不起来那个名字了，由冰岛那家公司运营的太空游戏。哦，EVE Online（星战前夜）？EVE Online，是的。它的描述看起来更像那样。但当QuantumLink来找我们问我们能做什么时，我们把这个提议从抽屉里拿了出来，他们感到非常非常兴奋。事情就这样一步步发展，然后我们经历了六八个月的律师谈判，因为这类事情就是这样运作的。
So maybe you were one of the lucky ones. Yeah. I don't want to hire unlucky people. Maybe they quote unquote lost the resume. That's actually a plot thread in, I think, some of Larry Niven's known space stories where he posits that in the future to limit population growth, they have the right to have children be the result of a lottery. And now, generations, they have selected for a population of people with genetically endowed luck. That's awesome.
但很明显这件事会成真，所以我花了六八个月的时间提前进行设计，同时等待律师敲定文书工作，这样我才能真正开始这个项目，或者雇人来做这些工作之类的事情。它演变成了一个设计，在漫长的过程中经历了一堆名字的更改，主要是因为商标问题。我们最终定下来的名字叫做Habitat，回想起来，这名字对它来说真是个烂名字，但名字往往就是这样。Habitat实际上是现在我们所称的大型多人在线游戏（MMO）的鼻祖。它是一群人，不仅仅是某个明确定义的知名游戏中的两三个或八个人。
So you joined Lucasfilm through the resume. And then were you sort of assigned to work on... Actually, before we even talk about that, so why don't you talk about what was Habitat or what is Habitat? Well, Habitat was a project... Well, actually, it does tie in a little bit to what was Lucasfilm about,
所以你是通过简历加入卢卡斯影业的。然后你被分配去从事……其实，在我们谈到这个之前，你为什么不谈谈什么是Habitat，或者Habitat是什么？嗯，Habitat是一个项目……嗯，其实，这确实跟卢卡斯影业是做什么的有点关系，
which is I ended up hiring on with Lucasfilm Games, which was not the graphics group doing the cool computer graphics. They were eventually spun off into another company, which we now know as Pixar. And they've come full circle and been reacquired, which is kind of cool. Yeah, they're both owned by Disney now, right? They're both owned by Disney now.
也就是我最后受雇于卢卡斯影业游戏部（Lucasfilm Games），它可不是做那些酷炫计算机图形的图形组。他们后来被分拆成另一家公司，也就是我们现在所知的皮克斯（Pixar）。它们兜兜转转又回到了原点，被重新收购了，这挺酷的。对，它们现在都归迪士尼所有，对吧？它们现在都归迪士尼所有。
When Lucasfilm had all of these really innovative sort of research groups doing advanced technical things for technology related to film and entertainment, and one of them was the computer graphics group. They had a digital audio group that some of them did the first audio signal processing work. And they had a games group, which was basically started because Atari gave them a chunk of money to do that. But then when they went through some corporate evolution, decided that they needed to spin these businesses off because it was too expensive and distracting,
当时卢卡斯影业拥有所有这些极具创新性的研究小组，为与电影和娱乐相关的技术从事先进的技术工作，其中之一就是计算机图形组。他们有一个数字音频组，其中一些人做了最早的音频信号处理工作。他们还有一个游戏组，这个组的成立基本上是因为雅达利（Atari）给了他们一笔钱来做这件事。但后来，当他们经历了某些企业重组后，决定需要将这些业务剥离出去，因为它们太昂贵也太让人分心了，
they kept the games group because it was actually producing entertainment products as opposed to technology. But our charter from George was, and I remember this very vividly because we had this amazing meeting. He said, your mission is to stay small, be the best, and don't lose any money. And so we had sort of pretty much free reign to do whatever the hell we wanted as long as somebody else paid for it. And that turned out not to be too hard because lots of people wanted to get close to the reflected glory of Star Wars and would come bring us money to do things.
他们保留了游戏组，因为它实际上在产生物乐娱乐产品，而不是技术。但乔治（George）给我们的宪章是——我对此记忆犹新，因为我们开过一次令人惊叹的会议——他说，你们的使命是保持规模小、做到最好、并且不能赔钱。所以我们基本上拥有为所欲为的自由，只要有别人为此买单。事实证明这并不太难，因为许多人都想沾一沾《星球大战》反射的光芒，并会带钱来找我们让我们做事。
And one year we were approached by a guy named Clive Smith, who was the VP of strategic planning for Commodore International. And they had undertaken a couple of strategic initiatives that year. One was the acquisition of of amiga and the other was a big investment in um so every year they would they would come out with a new guga to go with your commodore 64 and for the christmas season and this year it was going to be a really cheap 1200 baud modem and uh and as part that, they had made a strategic investment in a company called QuantumLink, which was an online service devoted to Commodore 64 users. And it was one of the first,
有一年，一个叫克莱夫·史密斯（Clive Smith）的人找到我们，他是康莫度国际（Commodore International）的战略规划副总裁。他们那一年开展了几项战略举措。一是对Amiga的收购，另一是对……的巨额投资，所以每年他们都会在圣诞节期间推出一款配合你的康莫度64（Commodore 64）的新配件，而今年将是一个非常便宜的1200波特调制解调器，作为其中的一部分，他们对一家名为QuantumLink的公司进行了战略投资，这是一家专门面向康莫度64用户的在线服务公司。它是最早的……
I think the first really consumer oriented things like that, where there were these online services that charged by the hour to use them, and they're quite expensive. Coffee serve would be $8 to $20 an hour. And in that environment, they were offering a service which was $3 an hour. And part of that was because they were only open evenings and weekends, purchasing unused network capacity from commercial X25 networks who mostly dealt with business customers. And then they did some really innovative things with, because it was all for the client, for the Commodore 64, they could do a custom client that optimized their use of the bandwidth and did all kinds of zippy interactive stuff and delivered a much more approachable sort of
我想这是最早真正面向消费者的同类服务之一，这些在线服务按使用小时收费，而且相当昂贵。CompuServe每小时收费8到20美元。在那种环境下，他们提供的服务是每小时3美元。部分原因是因为他们只在晚间和周末开放，从主要处理商业客户的商业X25网络购买未使用的网络容量。然后他们做了一些非常创新的事情，因为这完全是为了客户端，为了康莫度64，他们可以制作一个自定义客户端，优化他们对带宽的使用，做各种各样活泼的互动内容，并提供了一种更平易近人的……
consumer-oriented service and they were interested in games that would use this online service and of course Lucasfilm hey you know let's let's get them in it and and so they came to us and said what can you do for us and at the time when anybody in the games group had an idea, what they would do is they'd write up a two or three page sort of summary of their idea. And then, you know, it would get circulated around the group and discussed and ultimately find its way into a folder in our general manager's file cabinet. Steve Arnold, who ran things, would just keep this inventory of potential projects. And then when somebody would come shopping, he'd kind of gauge what they were interested in and pull some of these things out of his file cabinet and say, hey, well, we've got these things. And I had cooked up an idea for something along with my then office mate, Noah Falstein, for something we called Lucasfilms Universe, where we had started arguing about artificial intelligence for games. Wait, Noah, is Noah Falstein the secret of Monkey Island, I think?
面向消费者的服务，他们对会使用这种在线服务的游戏很感兴趣，当然还有卢卡斯影业，嘿，你知道的，让我们让他们参与进来，于是他们找到我们，问我们能为他们做些什么。当时，游戏组里的任何人有了点子，他们就会把自己的点子写成两三页的摘要。然后，你知道的，它会在小组里传阅并讨论，最终进入我们总经理文件柜里的一个文件夹。管理事务的史蒂夫·阿诺德（Steve Arnold）会保留这份潜在项目清单。然后当有人来物色项目时，他就会揣摩他们的兴趣，从文件柜里抽出一部分东西说，嘿，我们有这些东西。我和我当时的办公室搭档诺亚·法尔斯坦（Noah Falstein）一起构思了一个点子，我们称之为“卢卡斯影业宇宙”（Lucasfilms Universe），当时我们开始争论关于游戏的}}_。等等，诺亚，诺亚·法尔斯坦是《猴岛的秘密》（The Secret of Monkey Island）的……我想是吗？
No, that's Ron Gilbert. Oh. No, I think involved in Monkey Island. All of us were involved in all of these projects. But Monkey Island was mostly Ron's doing. I can tell you some stories. But anyway, one of the things that we were having this argument over lunch and I said, well, I don't know how to create an AI which is as rich and
不，那是罗恩·吉尔伯特（Ron Gilbert）。哦。不，我认为（他）参与了《猴岛》。我们所有人都参与了所有这些项目。但《猴岛》主要是罗恩的作品。我可以告诉你一些故事。总之，我们在午餐时为这个争论不休，我说，嗯，我不知道如何创造一个像……一样丰富且……
as subtle as an actual human being in terms of the interactivity that it can give you. But why don't we just connect you to another actual human being? And that spawned this kind of vague proposal for this multiplayer open universe thing that probably from its initial description looked a lot more like spacing on the name the space game that's run by the company in iceland oh uh eve online eve online yeah it's it the description looked a lot more like that but when quantum link came came to us and said what can you do we pulled this this proposal out of out of the drawer, and they got very, very excited. And one thing led to another, and then we had six or eight months of lawyers negotiating with each other because that's how these things work.
像真人一样微妙的人工智能，在它能给你的互动性方面。但为什么我们不直接把你连接到另一个真人呢？这就催生了这种关于多人开放宇宙玩法的模糊构思，从最初的描述来看，可能看起来更像是……脑海中想不起那个名字了，由冰岛一家公司运营的空间游戏，哦，呃，EVE Online（星战前夜），EVE Online，对，它的描述看起来更像是那样，但当QuantumLink来找我们问我们能做什么时，我们把这份提案从抽屉里拿了出来，他们变得非常非常兴奋。事情就这样一步接一步地发展了，然后我们花了六八个月的时间让律师们互相谈判，因为这些事情就是这么运作的。
But it was pretty clear it was going to happen, so I spent six or eight months doing design ahead while we were waiting for the lawyers to finalize the paperwork so I could actually start working on the project or like hiring people to do the work and stuff. And it evolved into a design for something that it went through a bunch of name changes along the way because of mostly because of trademark issues. And the name that we ended up settling on was something called Habitat, which in retrospect, I mean, it's a really dumb name for what it was, but names are like that. And Habitat was really the first, what we now call massively multiplayer online games. It was a bunch of, it wasn't just two or four or eight people in some well-defined game.
但很明显这件事会发生，所以我花了六八个月的时间在律师敲定文件期间提前进行设计，这样我才能真正开始从事这个项目，或者雇用人员来做这些工作之类的事情。它演变成了一种设计，在推进过程中经历了一堆名称变更，主要是因为商标问题。我们最终定下来的名字叫Habitat，回想起来，我的意思是，对于它是什么而言，这真的是一个很蠢的名字，但名字就是这样。Habitat确实是现在我们所称的大型多人在线游戏的鼻祖。它是一群……它不仅仅是某个定义明确的游戏中的两、四或八个人。
It was an open-ended, open-world thing that allowed, you know, these graphical figures that I called avatars to, you know, see each other, to move around, to talk, to interact. It was as much a social space as it was a game. It didn't have a lot of the explicit game goals that you get with something like World of Warcraft. It was much more like, I guess the closest modern analog would be something like Second Life, except that it was all on Commodore 64s and ran over 300 and 1200 baud modems over commercial packet switching networks. So was this like a text-based or what was the user interface? You can find screenshots of it. And in fact, as a result of a project that we did over the past few years, the Museum
这是一个开放式的、开放世界的系统，你知道，它允许这些我称之为化身的图形形象，你知道的，能够互相看到、走动、交谈和互动。它既是一个社交空间，也是一个游戏。它没有《魔兽世界》那种明确的游戏目标。它更像——我想最接近的现代类似物大概就是《第二人生》这样的东西，只不过它全部运行在Commodore 64上，并通过商业数据包交换网络使用300和1200波特的调制解调器。那么这是基于文本的还是用户界面是怎样的？你可以在网上找到它的截图。事实上，由于我们在过去几年里做的一个项目，
of Arts and Digital Entertainment, which is a video game museum in Oakland, California, sponsored a project called Neo Habitat, where we took the original Habitat client software running in a web browser in a Commodore 64 emulator, backhauled over the internet using emulated Commodore modem to a server that we reconstructed from the original Habitat source code. And you can go to neohabitat.org and you can actually play this game in all of its 8-bit glory
加州奥克兰的电子游戏博物馆——艺术与数字娱乐博物馆，赞助了一个名为“新栖息地”（Neo Habitat）的项目。我们在Commodore 64模拟器的网页浏览器中运行原始的Habitat客户端软件，通过模拟的Commodore调制解调器回传到互联网上，连接到我们从原始Habitat源代码重建的服务器。你可以访问neohabitat.org，亲身体验这款游戏的8位像素辉煌，
and 1200 baud bandwidth experience using the Commodore floppy disk drive, which is the world's slowest storage device. We were doing what essentially amounted to object-oriented virtual memory using a floppy disk drive. It's a graphical world and you can walk around and you can interact with other people
以及1200波特的带宽体验，使用的还是Commodore软盘驱动器——世界上最慢的存储设备。我们所做的基本上相当于利用软盘驱动器实现面向对象的虚拟内存。这是一个图形化的世界，你可以四处走动，与其他人互动，
and you can talk with them and do various other things. And it spawned a whole subculture of people who really, really got into playing this. And I've written extensively about this. Got it. So maybe this was in part like inspiration who really really got into playing this and i've written extensively about this got it so this so maybe this was like uh in part like inspiration for second life and world of warcraft and and all of these things that came afterwards randy farmer who was the main programmer i hired to work on
与他们交谈并做各种其他事情。它催生了一个庞大的亚文化群体，里面的人非常非常热衷于玩这个游戏。我曾就此写过大量文章。明白了。所以也许这在某种程度上算是一种灵感来源……非常非常热衷于玩这个游戏，我对此写过很多文章。明白了，所以也许这在某种程度上就像是《第二人生》、《魔兽世界》以及所有后来出现的事物的灵感来源。兰迪·法莫（Randy Farmer），我雇来参与这个项目的首席程序员，
this who eventually became a full partner in the whole enterprise and uh and i have uh to say written extensively about this talked about it a lot and it and it has had a lot of a lot of influence and we actually got the first i guess they call it now call it the uh pioneer award but at the time it's called the first penguin award from the igda which is that the game developers version of the academy of motion picture arts and sciences is sort of the the oscar of the computer games world for having kicked off the the mmo genre so just to recap a little bit so so the virtual reality stuff kind of makes makes you ill from from the motion sickness all of. So that's not necessarily your cup of tea. Your cup of tea is really the, like a lot of these sort of like social,
最终成为了整个企业和项目的完整合伙人，而且我可以说——我写过很多关于它的文章，也谈论过它很多次——它确实产生了非常深远的影响。我们实际上获得了——我想他们现在叫它“先驱奖”，但在当时被称为国际游戏开发者协会（IGDA）的第一届“企鹅奖”。该协会相当于电影艺术与科学学院的游戏开发者版本，某种程度上可以说是电脑游戏世界的奥斯卡奖，表彰我们开创了MMO（大型多人在线）类型。所以简单回顾一下——所以虚拟现实技术会让你有点恶心，因为会有晕动症，所以那不一定是你的菜。你的菜其实是像这种社交类的、
you know, multiplayer. One of the things that kind of discovered is in the course of doing this was that it's very easy as technologists to get very absorbed in the technology. And it is really interesting, but a lot of these systems have had the property of being, you know, sort of more interesting you know, $80,000 computers, early versions of head-mounted displays and various other things, interface devices,
你知道的多人游戏。在做这件事的过程中，我发现的一点是，作为技术人员，我们很容易过于沉迷于技术本身。这确实很有趣，但其中许多系统的特性是——你知道的，更有趣的其实是8万美元的电脑、早期版本的头戴式显示器以及各种其他东西，比如界面设备，
like there's a thing called the data glove, which was an instrumented glove that would capture your hand movements and other things. And there were lots of people who were thinking, oh, this is going to be so cool once it works. And so there was a conference called the First International Conference on Cyberspace that we heard about. Somebody said, you know, oh, you guys should talk at this conference.
有一个东西叫做数据手套（data glove），它是一个带有传感器的手套，可以捕捉你的手部动作以及其他动作。当时有很多人都在想：“哦，一旦这东西能用了，那可就太酷了。”然后我们听说了一个叫做“第一届国际网络空间会议”（First International Conference on Cyberspace）的会议。有人说：“你知道吗，你们应该在这个会议上做个演讲。”
And we learned about this like the day before the deadline for submission of abstract. And so we frantically threw together this really audacious abstract without having any real idea what it was we were going to say and faxed it off to them in a hurry. And then the paper ended up getting accepted. So we ended up writing this thing. And we go to this conference and there's all of these people talking about the things they'd done with their $80,000 Silicon Graphics workstations. And we had this thing where we were doing this thing with this $150 computer even $150 at Kmart. It was $10 at a garage sale because at that point, even the Commodore was basically well into obsolescence. And we talked about what we had done and what we had done was a lot more interesting in some ways than what the people with the big expensive hardware were doing. And part of it was what was forced on us by necessity.
我们得知这个消息时，距离摘要提交的截止日期只有一天了。于是我们手忙脚乱地拼凑了一份非常大胆的摘要，甚至没有真正想好我们要说些什么，就匆忙把它传真了过去。结果这篇论文居然被接收了。于是我们最终写了这篇东西。我们去参加了这个会议，那里所有人都在谈论他们用8万美元的硅谷图形工作站（Silicon Graphics workstations）做出来的事情。而我们做的东西，用的是一台价值150美元的电脑——在Kmart甚至只要150美元，在旧货摊上只要10美元，因为到了那个时候，连Commodore基本上都已经严重过时了。我们讲述了我们所做的事情，在某些方面，我们做的事比那些拥有昂贵大硬件的人所做的要有趣得多。部分原因是我们被客观条件逼迫出来的。
All the interesting stuff had to do with the interactions between the people online and the things that we discovered about things like community management and the interactions among a big user population and the kinds of emergent social structures and emergent behaviors that you got from that. And from our perspective was actually a lot more interesting and probably a lot more important than the actual underlying technology.
所有有趣的事情都与线上人们之间的互动有关，以及我们所发现的关于社区管理、庞大用户群体之间的互动，以及由此产生的各种涌现社会结构（emergent social structures）和涌现行为（emergent behaviors）有关。从我们的角度来看，这实际上比实际底层技术要有趣得多，可能也重要得多。
That makes sense. There was a project that really fascinated me called GTA MP. And the idea was they took GTA Grand Theft Auto 3, which was not multiplayer, or maybe it was, but just with a handful of people, or maybe not even multiplayer at all. And they somehow, I don't know if this was developers who quit and like, I don't understand tech from a technology perspective, how this was possible, but they were somehow able to take this game and make it massively multiplayer without having access to the source code i don't really know what what happened there that's yeah i don't i'm not familiar with that i mean there is there is a long tradition
这就说得通了。有一个项目曾经深深地吸引了我，叫做GTA MP。它的创意是，他们拿来了原本不是多人游戏的《侠盗猎车手3》（GTA 3）——或者也许它是，但只支持极少数人，甚至可能根本不是多人游戏——然后他们不知怎么地（我不知道这群人是不是离职的开发者，从技术角度我也理解不了这是怎么做到的），竟然能在没有源代码的情况下，把这款游戏改成支持大型多人在线。我真的不知道当时发生了什么。是的，我不太了解那个。我的意思是，长期以来一直存在着一种
of what is actually a terrible terrible engineering pattern of taking a what was otherwise a single user game and sort of sawing it in half and then stretching the two halves over the network. And usually the result of this is very unsatisfactory because it doesn't take into account all of the weirdnesses that happen when you actually have a network, including strange time lags and all of the sort of distributed data consistency issues and all of this kind of stuff. That is what makes these things technically challenging. So, yeah, I agree with you. I mean, from a tech standpoint, there's like all this warping, time warping and all sorts of weird behavior. But the thing that was interesting was, you know, when you started this thing, there's I think up to 200 people on one game on server and so when you started this thing it was exactly what you would expect when there's no consequences for dying like basically like i remember i joined the server and i got like someone kamikaze to 747 into me and i
其实非常非常糟糕的工程模式：把一个原本是单人用户的游戏从中间锯成两半，然后把这两半通过网络拉伸开来。通常这种做法的结果非常不尽如人意，因为它没有考虑到当你真正拥有一个网络时所发生的各种怪异现象，包括奇怪的延迟、所有分布式数据一致性问题以及诸如此类的各种事情。正是这些东西让这些技术变得充满挑战。所以，是的，我同意你的观点。从技术的角度来看，存在着各种扭曲、时间扭曲以及各种诡异的行为。但有趣的是，当你启动这个系统时，我记得一个服务器上有多达200个人。所以当你启动它时，情况正是你所预料的那样——当死亡没有任何后果时，基本上就像我记得我加入服务器时，有人开着波音747搞神风特攻队式地撞向我，我
just died and i woke up at the hospital and then uh in the game and then like you know another 747 crashed into me and it was just chaos but then and so i thought well yeah this is kind of what i would expect when you could just teleport anywhere and and and there's there's just total chaos but then like out of that sort of primordial chaos grew these servers where people had rules that, you know, there were administrators, and administrators forced, you know, rules and economics and scarcity and all these things. And then out of those rules came actually really interesting social hierarchies and social structures and all of that and um i just that seemed like that was just that blew my mind the fact that that all of that kind of emerged from this one sort of hack that all of that social
直接就死掉了，然后在医院醒来。接着呢，在游戏里，又有一架747撞了我，现场简直是一片混乱。但随后，在那种类似原始混沌的混乱之中，竟然诞生了这样一些服务器：人们在那里制定了规则，有了管理员，管理员强制推行规则、经济系统、稀缺性以及所有这些东西。然后，在这些规则之中，居然诞生了非常有趣的社会等级制度、社会结构以及所有这些。我只是觉得，这一切竟然能从这样一个最初的“黑客式”补丁中涌现出来，所有的这些社会
structure is built up on top of that that kind of evolution is is not an uncommon pattern one of the things that happened with with countertat is we had controversy because there are different different sort of styles of play. And there are some people who are into it more as an explicitly game kind of thing. And there are others who were just using it as a social space. And so we had put in weapons because, you know, it's a time-honored video game thing. And there are some people who are very, very upset by that and didn't like any kind of even performatively violent stuff going on at all.
结构都建立在那种演进之上，这种现象其实并不罕见。在《栖息地》中发生的事情之一是，我们遇到了争议，因为玩家有不同类型的玩法。有些人更热衷于把它当作一个纯粹的游戏，而另一些人则只是把它当作一个社交空间。所以我们引入了武器，因为你知道的，这是电子游戏历史悠久的传统。有些对此非常非常反感，根本不喜欢任何哪怕是表演性质的暴力内容发生。
And so what we did is we had different parts of the world. So in town was what was a weapons free zone. I mean, you could carry them, but they wouldn't work. And then sort of out in the hinterlands was sort of the Wild West and anything goes. And so the people who were interested in doing just purely social stuff would hang out in town where all the other people were. And the people who were wanting to do combat and that kind of thing would go out in the woods and shoot it out we had the major form of avatar customization that you could do given the limitations of the graphics technology at the time was substituting your your avatar's head and there was a palette of 256 different heads that we had provided that you could
所以我们采取的做法是将世界划分成不同的区域。比如镇上是一个“无武器区”（weapons free zone）。我的意思是，你可以随身携带武器，但它们无法使用。而在偏远的腹地则是所谓的“狂野西部”，百无禁忌。因此，那些只想进行纯粹社交活动的人会和大家一起聚在镇上，而那些想要进行战斗及类似活动的人则会去树林里火拼。当时受限于图形技术的局限性，我们能提供的主要化身（avatar）自定义方式是替换你化身的头部。我们提供了一个包含256种不同头部的调色板，供你
swap in and out but it wasn't just that you got to pick one of these 256 heads you had to get a head from somewhere um so you'd go to the head shop and there would be a vending machine that sold heads and some were more scarce than others and so if you want to swap your head you have to take your head off and put it on the ground and then pick up a different head and put it on and people discovered you just take some something and put it on the ground somebody else could pick it up and run away with it and so the question is how do you execute a trade it's like i'll swap you this thing for for that really cool head you have yeah you need to set up like escrow services now well indeed in in in some later systems we we did exactly that but but i think world of warcraft has an escrow service yeah they have
自由更换。但不仅仅是你可以在这256个头部中任选一个，你还得从某个地方弄到一个头部才行。所以你要去“头像店”，那里会有出售头部的自动售货机，有些头部比其他的更稀缺。因此，如果你想更换头像，你必须先把头摘下来放在地上，然后再捡起另一个头像戴上。人们发现，如果你把某种东西放在地上，别人就可以把它捡起来并带走。于是问题来了：你该如何进行交易？比如“我用这个东西换你那个超级酷的头像”。是的，你得建立托管服务（escrow services）之类的机制了。确实如此，在后来的某些系统中，我们确实做了完全相同的事情。不过我认为《魔兽世界》就有托管服务，对吧？他们有一个
a little third panel. So I'll give a bit of background for people who have never bought a house. The way it works when you buy a house is very similar to the way you trade items in World of Warcraft, where you give the money to a third party person who both you and the seller trust. The seller gives the deed to that person. And so there's a moment in time where you don't have the money and that person doesn't have their house.
小的第三面板。那我为那些从未买过房子的人提供一点背景知识。买房子时的运作方式，非常类似于你在《魔兽世界》中交易物品的方式：你把钱交给一个你和卖家都信任的第三方人员，卖家则把房契交个这个人。所以在某个时间点，你没有了钱，而那个人也没有拿到房子。
This third party person has both of those things, but you both have to trust that person not to steal from both of you, right? And that's why usually some big institution and then that escrow service then gives each person the item from the other person and world of warcraft had something similar where you know if i wanted to trade a sword for a shield it's been forever since i played this but but uh you
这个第三方人员同时拥有这两样东西，但你们双方都必须信任这个人，相信他不会把你们两人的东西都偷走，对吧？这就是为什么通常需要某个大型机构来做这件事。然后，托管服务会将对方的物品交给每个人。《魔兽世界》里也有类似的机制，你知道的，如果我想用一把剑换一面盾牌——虽然我玩这个游戏已经是很久以前的事了，但
know i would drag my sword into this thing they would drag their shield there's also a delay so like they couldn't drag their shield out right before I clicked accept or anything like that. There is this anytime someone edited anything in the escrow, it grayed out all the buttons. Well, you need an interlock where both parties have committed to the same state of things before actually execute the transfer of ownership. Yeah. We actually did in a later later system not in habitat we actually one of the first things we did was implement what we call the trading machine which which essentially followed exactly the pattern you described there largely as a result of this experience with people stealing stuff from
你知道的，我会把剑拖进这个界面，对方会把盾牌拖进去。这里面还有一个延迟机制，所以在你点击“接受”之前，对方无法把盾牌临时拖走。无论何时只要有人在托管界面中编辑任何内容，所有的按钮都会变成灰色。嗯，你需要一个互锁机制（interlock），让双方在真正执行所有权转移之前，都对事物的同一状态做出承诺。是的。事实上，在后来的系统中——而不是在《栖息地》中，我们做的第一件事之一就是实现我们所谓的“交易机”（trading machine），它基本上完全遵循了你刚才描述的模式，这在很大程度上正是由于吸取了人们在《栖息地》中互相偷东西的教训。
each other when they could inhabit well one of the things that happened is we didn't have any means technologically at that point to to that. But people were nevertheless upset. We said, well, what do you want to do? And people, the users said, well, we want to have a sheriff. And so we whipped together some code to create a voting machine, which we could do relatively easily. And the users themselves organized a thing where they had a couple of people who put themselves forward as candidates for sheriff. And they had a big candidates debate
在《栖息地》中发生的事情之一是，我们当时在技术上没有任何手段来阻止这种行为。但人们仍然感到很不高兴。我们问：“那你们想怎么做？”用户们回答说：“我们想要一个治安官（sheriff）。”于是我们迅速拼凑了一些代码来创建一个投票机，这对我们来说相对容易做到。用户们自己组织了一场活动，推出几个人作为治安官候选人。他们举办了一场大型的候选人辩论会，
where people came and asked them questions and they answered the questions. And then they held an election. And then this one person was elected sheriff and we gave him a special avatar head that had a big 10 gallon hat with a star on top of it. And he was the sheriff. And literally all he had was this special hat, but also he had some moral authority. I was assuming that the sheriff could just insta-kill people or something. No, actually all he had was a hat.
人们来向候选人提问，候选人进行回答。接着他们举行了选举。最后这个人当选了治安官，我们给他分配了一个特殊的化身头部，上面戴着一顶带有星星的大牛仔帽。他就是治安官。实际上他拥有的全部东西就只有这顶特殊的帽子，但他同时拥有道德权威。我还以为治安官可以直接秒杀其他人或者什么的。不，实际上他除了那顶帽子什么都没有。
But like I said, he had moral authority. And what was surprising was it was remarkably effective, given that he had no actual authority to actually do anything. He merely carried with him the support from the community. And that turned out to be sufficient you know given that the user population was was really huge for that day but small by current standards like 15 000 people or something you know he could go talk to folks and say hey that was really not cool you should give that back and um well 1500 people but that's that's probably there's probably no sharding right like world of warcraft has so many people but it'sarded, so you really only see a handful. Yeah, well, we have a completely different way to distribute the load and how it all got handled in terms of scaling. And in fact, the architecture from Habitat has propagated forward into the future.
但正如我所说，他拥有道德权威。令人惊讶的是，考虑到他实际上没有任何真正的权力去执行任何事情，这种做法却出奇地有效。他仅仅随身携带着来自社区的支持。事实证明，这就足够了。考虑到当时的用户群体规模——按当时的眼光来看真的非常巨大，但按现在的标准来看很小，大概15,000人左右——他可以去和大家交谈，说：“嘿，那样做真的一点都不酷，你应该把它还给人家。”嗯，1500人，不过那可能——可能没有分片（sharding）机制吧？就像《魔兽世界》有那么多玩家，但它是分片的，所以你实际上只能看到一小撮人。对的，我们在分担负载以及如何处理整个扩展性问题上，采用了一种完全不同的方式。事实上，《栖息地》的架构已经延续并传承到了未来。
And we've gone and implemented several different generations of servers over the course of various Silicon Valley adventures with different companies, ultimately culminating in something that I managed to get pride loose when we did a version of this at Yahoo and got released as open source. And so I have a server platform called Elko that is linked from my blog and it's got, you know, you can get all the source for it. It's on GitHub and you can just use this. And this thing scales like crazy for a given the kind of scaling model that we had. And our model was instead of having different pieces of you know having basically different shards of the world instead what happens is each each little piece of the world is a is a separate is a separate place and then you just you you load the parts of the world that people are actually using into the into the server and then when you go from one
在硅谷经历过几家公司的各种历险过程中，我们已经去实现了好几代不同的服务器，最终促成了一个项目：当我们在雅虎做这个项目的一个版本时，我设法将其开源并发布了出去。所以我有一个名为Elko的服务器平台，我的博客上有它的链接，你可以在上面获取它的所有源代码。它在GitHub上，你完全可以直接使用。考虑到我们所采用的扩展模型，这个东西的扩展能力简直疯狂。我们的模型是：不是去拥有不同的、基本上是世界不同分片的架构，而是让世界的每一个小部分都是一个独立的、单独的地方，然后你只需要把人们实际正在使用的世界的那一部分加载到服务器中。接着，当你从一个
place to another you essentially have a handoff from one server to another. Today's sponsor is Mergify. Mergify is a tool for GitHub that prioritizes, queues, automatically merges, comments, rebases, updates, labels, backports, closes, and assigns your pull requests. Mergify features allow you to automate what you would normally do manually. You can secure your code using a merge queue,
地方走到另一个地方时，本质上就是在一台服务器和另一台服务器之间进行移交（handoff）。今天的赞助商是Mergify。Mergify是一个针对GitHub的工具，可以对你的拉取请求（pull request）进行优先排序、排队、自动合并、评论、变基（rebase）、更新、打标签、回溯移植（backport）、关闭和指派。Mergify的功能允许你将平时需要手动完成的操作自动化。你可以使用合并队列（merge queue）来保护你的代码，
automatically merge it, and many more features. By saving time, you and your team can focus on projects that matter. Mergeify can coordinate with any CI and is fully integrated into GitHub. They have a startup program that could give your company a 12-month credit to leverage Mergify. That's up to $21,000 of value. Start saving time. Visit Mergify.com to sign up for a demo and get started.
自动将其合并，并享受更多功能。通过节省时间，你和你的团队可以专注于重要的项目。Mergify可以与任何持续集成（CI）系统协调工作，并与GitHub完全集成。他们提供了一个初创公司计划，可以为你的公司提供12个月的额度来利用Mergify，价值高达21,000美元。开始节省时间吧。访问Mergify.com注册以获取演示并开始使用。
Or just follow the link in the show notes. Back to the episode. Yes, I mean, this is similar to how the cell phone network works. Like when you're on the highway, you know, your phone is getting handed off from one cell tower to the other, and there's a bit of overlap. But well, it was interesting is we have a very different scaling strategy from the web, and it's often hard to explain to web people. It's funny because I've had conversations with web people and games people, and last time I was actually deeply engaged with this server technology was about 10 years ago.
或者直接点击节目简介中的链接。回到本集节目。是的，我的意思是，这类似于手机网络的运作方式。就像你在高速公路上行驶时，你的手机会在不同的手机信号塔之间进行切换交接，并且会有一点重叠区域。不过有趣的是，我们采用的扩展策略与Web有很大不同，通常很难向做Web开发的人解释清楚。有趣的是，我和Web开发人员以及游戏开发人员都进行过交流，上一次我真正深入参与这种服务器技术大约是在10年前。
We had a company that was doing some, in this case, we were using the same server backend, but we were doing mobile games, geo-based mobile games. And I was saying, well, you know, we can handle about 250,000 concurrent users per server. And you say that number to web guys and they're like, no, no, that's not possible. And you say that to games guys and they're like, no, no, that's not possible. And you say that to games people and they say, yes, sure, so what?
当时我们有一家公司在做一些——在这个案例中，我们使用的是相同的服务器后端，但我们做的是移动游戏，基于地理位置的移动游戏。我说过：“嗯，你知道的，我们每个服务器可以处理大约25万个并发用户。”你对Web开发人员说出这个数字，他们的反应是：“不，不，这不可能。”而你对游戏开发人员说这话，他们的反应也是：“不，不，这不可能。”然后你对游戏圈的人说，他们的反应则是：“对啊，当然可以，那又怎样？”
It's just a different perspective. And it's because the architecture is oriented to fundamentally different kinds of operations and use of the network. I think the HTTP in particular is a very inefficient protocol. My sort of cynical way of putting it is like the most expensive thing you can do with a TCP IP network is open a new connection. That's like the highest overhead thing that you can do. And so I think that the philosophy of HTTP is, well, it's this expensive operation. So if you do it a lot, we must be providing you a lot of value. And web servers will try very, very hard. The thing that they really are deep down in their hearts jonesing
这只是视角的不同。这是因为架构的面向根本上是针对不同类型的操作和网络使用的。我认为特别是HTTP，是一个非常低效的协议。我对其进行的一种愤世嫉俗的说法是：你用TCP/IP网络能做的最昂贵的事情，就是打开一个新的连接。那是你所能做的开销最高的事情。因此，我认为HTTP的哲学是：“好吧，这是一个昂贵的操作。所以如果你经常这样做，我们一定是在为你提供很多价值。”Web服务器会非常非常努力地工作。它们内心深处最渴望、
to do is to close the connection because they think an open TCP connection is like super expensive. It's a super expensive resource. And the answer is no, it's not actually a super expensive resource. It's actually a very cheap resource. What's super expensive is having like an entire process devoted to that connection. I wonder if there's a connection between or if there's a semantic connection between the fact that HTTP is such an ephemeral thing. It wants to open the connection, do something really quick, like send you a JPEG or something, and then kill the connection. I wonder if there's a causal link between that and the short attention spans we talked about earlier. That's an interesting take, because a lot of the stuff that we've done has been based on
最想做的事情就是关闭连接，因为它们认为一个打开的TCP连接就像是超级昂贵的资源。这是一个超级昂贵的资源。而答案是：不，它其实不是一个超级昂贵的资源。它实际上是一个非常便宜的资源。真正超级昂贵的是为该连接分配一整套进程。我在想，HTTP这种转瞬即逝的特性（它想要打开连接，做一些非常快的事情，比如给你发送一张JPEG图片，然后就掐断连接），这与我们之前谈到的注意力短暂之间，是否存在某种语义上的联系呢？或者说它们之间是否存在某种因果联系？这是一个很有意思的看法，因为我们所做的大多数事情都是基于
long-lived persistent connections. And having a single server that just had a couple hundred thousand open TCP connections to different clients, it turns out a modern computer can handle that just fine. Now, that computer is only running half a dozen processes to manage all of that stuff, which is why we can sustain it. But there's a whole set of dogma about statelessness that figures very heavily into the scaling story that the web employs. And you get a lot of leverage from that. And for the kinds of things that the web does, this notion that you can horizontally replicate web servers that are completely decoupled from each other and basically scale arbitrarily wide because you have this stateless protocol is actually very powerful. And it's something that they've leveraged tremendously. What that story leaves out is that, in fact, actual real user applications that human beings use have state associated with them.
长生命周期的持久连接。事实证明，拥有一个只需对不同客户端保持几十万个打开的TCP连接的单一服务器，现代计算机完全可以应付自如。现在，这台计算机只运行了寥寥几个进程来管理所有这些东西，这就是为什么我们能够维持它。但关于无状态性（statelessness）存在着一整套教条，这在Web所采用的扩展故事中占据了非常大的比重。并且你可以从中获得很多杠杆作用。对于Web所做的事情来说，这种认为你可以水平复制完全解耦的Web服务器，并且由于采用了这种无状态协议而基本上可以任意规模扩展的观念，实际上是非常强大的。这也是他们得到了巨大利用的东西。那个故事所遗漏的是，事实上，人类用户所使用的实际真实用户应用程序是带有状态的。
And typically the way that state gets maintained because everything is short-lived is in a database. And so what ends up happening is you end up using the SQL database, typically as your short-term memory bus, which is, once again, a really super expensive way to do that. Yep. Or you'll use like Redis or Dynamo or whatever. Yeah, there's a whole bunch of different tricks that they've taken to take this fundamentally inefficient thing and make it go fast. Whereas our approach was to say, no, all of this stuff is just state that's in memory. And then what you do is instead of moving the state around by passing it through a database, you move the users around by controlling which server and which process they're connected to. It's almost like a user is like a sort of like a Docker container or something that could be like containerized. That's actually a reasonably good, good model.
并且通常情况下，由于一切都是短暂的，状态的维护方式是通过数据库。因此最终发生的情况是，你最终会使用SQL数据库作为你的短期内存总线，这再一次是一种超级昂贵的做法。是的。或者你会使用Redis、Dynamo之类的东西。是的，他们采取了一大堆不同的技巧，把这个本质上低效的东西变得运行快速。而我们的方法则是说：“不，所有这些东西都只是内存中的状态。”然后你要做的不是通过将状态传递到数据库中来四处移动状态，而是通过控制用户连接到哪个服务器和哪个进程来四处移动用户。这几乎就像是一个用户就像是一个Docker容器或者可以被容器化的东西一样。这实际上是一个相当不错的好模型。
And I've written up this sort of scaling story once again on, on Habitat Chronicles and, and you can read all about it. And it's not even a particularly exotic thing. It's just a different philosophy for how you spread the load out. And rather than spreading out the individual HTTP request, you spread out the different interaction contexts. And one of the things that this allows you to do, which is really cutting against the grain for the web, is the model of the web is very, I guess you say it's very autistic. You talk to the server and the server talks back to you and that's it. Whereas in our system, you send a message to the server, which can result in
我也把这种扩展故事写下来并发表在《Habitat Chronicles》上了，大家可以去阅读了解全部内容。这甚至不是什么特别奇异的东西，它只是关于如何分摊负载的一种不同哲学。与分摊单个HTTP请求不同，你分摊的是不同的交互上下文。这允许你做的一件事情，是真正与Web的传统背道而驰的——Web的模型非常……我想你可以说它非常“自闭”（autistic）。你对服务器说话，服务器对你说话，仅此而已。而在我们的系统中，你向服务器发送一条消息，这可能会导致
a message going to some different user, or the server has some autonomous process that's going on and it at some point decides it wants to send a message to you. And it's not that you can't do these things in the web. I mean, people have done these things in the web and they do them all the time, but it is kind of cutting against the grain of how it works fundamentally and whereas we just sort of embrace that more more directly yeah that makes sense you know i think the i think a lot of people um you know get into computer science through games right right? I think that they play games and then they see these amazing virtual worlds. They see the fact that,
消息发送给某个不同的用户，或者服务器正在运行某个自主进程，并且它在某个时间点决定想要向你发送一条消息。这并不是说你不能在Web中做到这些事情——我的意思是，人们已经在Web中做过这些事情，而且他们一直在这样做——但这确实有点违背了它运作的基本方式，而我们只是更直接地拥抱了这一点。是的，这说得通。你知道的，我认为——我认为很多人通过游戏进入了计算机科学领域，对吧？我认为他们玩游戏，然后看到了这些神奇的虚拟世界。他们看到这样一个事实：
and maybe this isn't true anymore, but at least when I was playing games for Atari and for Commodore, you'd see a handful of names on the creators of the game. And I would always think like wow these three people made this thing that that uh is creating like hundreds of hours of entertainment just for me so so it's like imagine if you scale this out it's like three people let's say those people
也许现在情况已经不是这样了，但至少当我在为Atari和Commodore玩游戏时，你会看到游戏创作者名单上只有区区几个名字。我总是会想：“哇，这三个人制作了这个东西，仅仅为了我一个人就创造了数百小时的娱乐体验。”所以这就像是，想象一下如果你把这个规模扩大：三个人——假设这些人
worked for six months so in one one and a half people years of effort, you know, they created millions of people years of entertainment. And I always thought that was really amazing. And I think that resonates with a lot of folks. But then, you know, you contrast that with all the sort of horror stories of working in the games industry. And so that's actually what drove me to not be interested in working on games. But I was wondering what your take was on all of that. Well, it's interesting because my younger son, a few years ago, graduated from University of California, Santa Cruz with a degree in computer science game design.
工作了六个月，也就是1.5个人年的努力，他们就为数百万人创造了数百万年的娱乐体验。我一直觉得这真的太了不起了。我想这也引起了很多人的共鸣。但是，随后你将其与游戏行业中工作的种种恐怖故事进行对比，这实际上就是促使我对从事游戏工作不感兴趣的原因。不过我想知道你对这一切有什么看法。嗯，这很有趣，因为我小儿子几年前从加州大学圣克鲁兹分校毕业，获得了计算机科学游戏设计的学位。
Because he had exactly that sense of it's so cool, you know, being able to just create stuff. And what was interesting was the games program at Santa Cruz, which is quite good. in the traditional computer science program where they dispense with some of the more esoteric, more mathematical stuff with more emphasis on things like project management and team dynamics and a lot of that stuff. Here you have a group of people who are trying to get something done collectively. How do you coordinate them? How do you deal with the intra-team social dynamics and all of that kind of stuff? And ended up deciding for exactly the reasons you just cited, that he did not want to work in the games industry because it was very abusive to its developers in a lot of companies. I mean, there are a lot of great companies that aren't like that, but there is this,
因为他完全有着那种“能够亲手创造东西感觉太酷了”的想法。有趣的是，圣克鲁兹分校的游戏专业相当不错。与传统的计算机科学专业相比，他们省去了一些更深奥、更数学化的内容，转而更加强调项目管理、团队动力学以及诸如此类的事情。在这里，你会有一群人试图共同完成某件事情。你如何协调他们？你如何处理团队内部的社会动力学以及所有这类事情？他最终出于你刚才提到的原因，决定不想在游戏行业工作，因为许多公司的游戏开发商受到的对待非常糟糕。我的意思是，有很多伟大的公司并非如此，但确实存在着一种
there is this sort of tropism towards driving people too hard. But it turns out that his, his, his training, which had emphasized a lot of this more sort of practical sort of social components of the software development process was a great background for doing all kinds of software engineering stuff. And he's now working at Google and is very happy there. And the training he got in games development turns out to be a much better match to the real world of software engineering than a lot of computer science programs actually give you, simply because of this emphasis on the project management
过度驱使员工的倾向。不过事实证明，他的训练——该训练强调了软件开发过程中许多更具实用性的社交组件——为他从事各种软件工程工作打下了极好的基础。他现在在谷歌工作，在那里非常开心。事实证明，他在游戏开发中受到的训练比许多计算机科学专业实际提供的更能完美契合软件工程的真实世界，这仅仅是因为该专业强调了项目管理
and team dynamics side of things. Well, okay, so there's some, I mean, Google is a good example. So at Google, you know, there are projects, there aren't extremely strict, well, there's people working on hardware, but for the most most part there isn't a very strict deadline so it's like we have you know we have a new version of youtube and if it's two weeks late it's you know it's not the end of the world and so people march forward in that way is is that what makes the games industry kind of notorious for driving people? Is it the fact that like this game has to come out on this day? Or what is it about the games industry? Well, I'm not sure. I mean, I've kind of been out of the games industry for a while. So I'm
和团队动力学这一侧面。好吧，所以有些——我的意思是，谷歌就是一个很好的例子。所以在谷歌，你知道的，有很多项目，并没有极其严格的——好吧，有人在做硬件，但大多数情况下并没有非常严格的截止日期。所以感觉就像是：我们有——我们有一个新版本的YouTube，如果它晚了两个星期，你知道的，这也并非世界末日。所以大家就是以这种方式向前推进。是什么让游戏行业以“压榨员工”而闻名呢？是因为这个游戏必须在这一天发布吗？还是游戏行业的什么特质导致的？嗯，我不确定。我的意思是，我离开游戏行业已经有一段时间了。所以
probably not the best person to comment on the current state of how things work. But certainly, and I think to some extent, this is still true, there was a fairly tight coupling to the Christmas shopping season. And so one of the major peaks in sales volume was people buying games for friends and family as Christmas gifts. And so there is enormous premium on making sure that your title was in the store in time for the Christmas shopping season.
我可能不是评论当前运作状态的最佳人选。但当然，而且我认为在某种程度上这依然是真的，当时与圣诞购物季存在着相当紧密的绑定。因此，销售额的主要高峰之一是人们购买游戏作为送给朋友和家人的圣诞礼物。所以确保你的产品在圣诞购物季到来之前摆上货架，有着极其巨大的溢价。
And obviously the distribution channels have changed enormously now. For example, games are almost entirely distributed online, whereas in the earlier generation, you actually had a retail package that had to be put in a box and shipped to stores, which increased the lead time. So the way we used to say to Lucasfilm is that Christmas is in August. make the ship date for this year's Christmas shopping season, it meant that you either released after Christmas, in which case you missed all of the sales and your return was much, much lower, or you were delayed a year, which had capital cost. And given the rapid evolution of the technology, it meant that you had a game that was a year behind the curve in terms of the technology that people expected. And so I think that seasonal component is not as pronounced as it once was,
而且现在分销渠道已经发生了巨大的变化。例如，游戏几乎完全是通过在线分销的，而在早期，你实际上需要一个零售包装，必须把它装在盒子里运送到商店里，这增加了前置时间。所以我们以前对卢卡斯影业（Lucasfilm）说的是：“圣诞节是在8月份。”如果你想赶上当年圣诞购物季的发货日期，这意味着你要么在圣诞节后发布，那样的话你就会错过所有的销售，回报会低得多；要么你就得延期一年，这会产生资本成本。鉴于技术的快速演进，这意味着你的游戏在人们期望的技术曲线上落后了一年。因此，我认为这种季节性因素不像以前那么明显了，
but I think it's still there. And there's also, once you have started to spin up the sales and marketing machine to start promoting something, you're investing a lot of money in, if nothing else, all of the sales and marketing people that you've got working on it. And at that point, you're talking about making a pretty large expenditure in advance of when you can expect to see any revenue come back. So if you spin up a big sales and marketing organization, and then the product is delayed two months. Well, you're paying all of those people's salary to be sitting around for two months without a product to sell. That's very
但我认为它依然存在。而且，一旦你开始启动销售和营销机器来宣传某样东西，你就在其中投入了大量的资金——如果别的没有，至少有你雇来从事这项工作的全套销售和营销人员。在那个时间点上，在你期望看到任何收入回报之前，你已经在谈论一笔相当庞大的支出了。所以如果你启动了一个庞大的销售和营销组织，然后产品延期了两个月，好吧，你得支付所有这些人的薪水，让他们白坐两个月却没有任何产品可卖。这非常
expensive. And that dynamic is across the software industry. I think it's probably a dynamic that applies to many, many industries, but it's worse in software because of our terrible ability to do scheduling and planning. This is a question which has obsessed me since almost the start of my career, which is why is it so hard to plan and schedule software development? And my hypothesis is that because it's designed all the way down. Yeah, I was actually just about to say the same thing. Yeah, to take another industry
昂贵。这种动态贯穿整个软件行业。我认为这可能是一种适用于许多许多行业的动态，但在软件行业更糟糕，因为我们在做时间安排和规划方面能力太差了。这是一个从我职业生涯几乎一开始就一直困扰我的问题：为什么软件开发的计划和排期会如此困难？我的假设是，因为它是从头到尾全盘设计的。是的，我其实正准备说同样的话。是的，如果换作另一个
that I have some exposure to, which is feature film production. I used to work for Lucasfilm. Even though Hollywood is notorious for some quite famous budget blowouts and schedule overruns. For the most part, they're actually quite good at scheduling and managing costs. And part of this is because once you have a shooting script, you can plan out the filming and post-production process pretty reliably from that because you have this plan that you're working from. And when you're spending $200 million to make your
我也有所接触的行业——故事片制作（feature film production），我以前曾在卢卡斯影业工作过。尽管好莱坞以某些相当著名的预算暴雷和工期延误而闻名，但在大多数情况下，他们在排期和成本控制方面其实做得相当不错。部分原因在于，一旦你有了拍摄剧本（shooting script），你就可以根据这个相当可靠地规划拍摄和后期制作流程，因为你有一份可以依循的计划。当你花2亿美元去制作你的
feature film, the cost of the script is, even if you've got a very highly paid screenwriter writing your script, the cost of the script is kind of a round-off error in terms of the overall cost of the production. And so if it took two weeks to write the script or if it took two years, it kind of doesn't matter because that all happened at the beginning when you weren't spending very much money. Whereas when you're doing software, by the time you have a description of the product that is sufficiently detailed, that you could actually say, how long is that going to take?
故事片时，剧本的成本——即使你请了片酬极高的编剧来写剧本——就整体制作成本而言，基本上也只是一个可以忽略不计的舍入误差。所以如果写剧本花了两个星期或者花了两年，其实都无所谓，因为这一切都发生在刚开始、你还没花多少钱的时候。然而，当你做软件时，等你终于有了一份足够详细的产品描述，让你能够实际说出“这需要花多长时间”的时候，
Well, that is the product. You are done. It is 100% the design process. And everything short of the finished product is an approximation where there's a bunch of stuff in it that you don't understand yet because you haven't delved into them well enough to know what you're going to be doing. And why I like to say this is we in the software business don't know what we're doing. And I don't mean that in the sense of being incompetent, although that is sometimes a problem, but just in the sense of you only find
好吧，那已经是最终产品了。你已经完成了。这100%就是设计过程。而任何逊于最终产品的东西都只是一种近似，其中包含了大量你目前还不理解的东西，因为你还没有深入钻研到足以知道你到底要做什么的程度。为什么我喜欢这样说呢？我们在软件行业里根本不知道自己在干什么。我这话不是指大家不称职，尽管这有时确实是个问题，而只是指：只有在实际去做某件事情的过程中，
out in the doing of something what is involved. And I kind of come towards a philosophy of this, that software is not so much a design process as it is a discovery process, that you are in the course of doing it, you are learning what it is that you're doing you are figuring it out as you go along and that is kind of a necessary irreducible aspect of of the process and people would like to pretend that it's not so but they're wrong yeah i mean i i think a good analogy is if you look at some of these like massive works of art like the sistine chapel or something like it's it's it's the the roof of that is all one giant mural that is all kind of flowing and if you decide to like you can't decide to sort of change the color scheme or something like that like you've you've committed to that and if you do decide to make
你才会发现其中涉及了什么。我对这方面逐渐形成了一种哲学：软件与其说是一个设计过程，不如说是一个发现过程。你在做的过程中，正在了解你到底在做什么，你是一边做一边摸索出来的。这可以说是该过程中一种必要且不可约简的方面，人们愿意假装它不是这样的，但他们错了。是的，我的意思是——我认为一个很好的类比是，如果你看看某些像西斯廷教堂（Sistine Chapel）那样的大型艺术作品，它的屋顶全都是一幅巨大的壁画，整体浑然一体、流畅连贯。如果你决定——你不能随便决定去改变配色方案什么的，因为你已经对此做出了承诺，如果你确实决定去做……
even you know subtle changes that you can make it's going to be extremely time consuming because it's this sort of web like this thematic web and um um you know if you change one end of it you actually have to change the the whole thing um and so yeah i feel like i feel like it's a it's kind of an art process like that that has to be sort of thematically and like stylistically sort of consistent and uh yeah that makes a lot sense so is there a is there like a contemporary game you know that that gives you sort of those habitat you know you could have played it or you could have read about it but it gives you sort of those habitat kind of vibes like we talked about it, but it gives you sort of those Habitat kind of vibes. Like we talked about EVE Online.
即使你知道可以做出一些微小的改变，这也将极其耗时，因为这是一种网状结构，一种主题网，嗯，嗯，你知道，如果你改变了它的一端，实际上你必须改变整个东西……所以，是的，我觉得，我觉得这有点像一个艺术过程，它必须在主题和风格上保持一致，嗯，是的，这很有意义，那么，有没有，有没有像当代游戏那样，能给你那种栖息地感觉的，你知道的，你可能玩过它，也可能读过关于它的文章，但它能给你那种Habitat（栖息地）的感觉？就像我们讨论过的那样，但它能给你那种Habitat（栖息地）的感觉。就像我们讨论过的《EVE Online》。
Are there other sort of social games where you can say that? I would say the closest modern parallel to Habitat is Second Life. Now, Second Life is, I'm not sure what state they're in at the moment. I've been away from that world for a while. What I'm working on now is, although it's certainly inspired by some of the technical roots of some of the things I've done, I'm not that was doing geo-based games. I think things like Ingress and Pokemon Go are scratching the surface of what I think is possible in that space. And I think there's some very exciting possibilities there that are woefully underexplored. And I'm really surprised that there hasn't been more sort of experimentation in that area. As far as what's going on right now, I don't know.
还有其他类似的游戏可以这样说吗？我会说，最接近Habitat的现代平行产物就是《第二人生》（Second Life）。现在，《第二人生》——我不太清楚他们目前的状态。我离开那个世界已经有一段时间了。我现在正在做的事情，虽然它当然受到我过去做过的一些事情的技术根源的启发，但我当时并不是在做基于地理的游戏。我认为像《Ingress》和《Pokemon Go》这样的游戏只是触及了我认为该领域可能性的表面。而且我认为那里有一些非常令人兴奋的可能性，但却被严重地低估了。我真的很惊讶该领域没有进行更多形式的实验。至于现在的情况，我不知道。
I've been unplugged from the games world for a while. I am sort of increasingly down in the weeds of the technology stack. And, you know, it's a happy place to be because you can just have sort of more control over your universe there. Why don't you elaborate a little bit? What are you up to now? What's been your recent focus? So I'm currently working for a company called Agoric, which was started sort of community of folks who have been in each other's business on and off, in and out, in different permutations and combinations over the years,
我从游戏世界中脱离出来有一段时间了。我最近越来越深入技术栈的底层。而且，你知道，这是一个令人愉快的地方，因为你可以在那里对你的宇宙有更多的控制。你为什么不详细阐述一下呢？你现在在做什么？你最近的重点是什么？所以我目前在一家名为Agoric的公司工作断断续续、进进出出、以不同的排列组合共事过的一群社区人员，
in various different startups and companies doing things. And this is sort of one of the latest manifestations of that. Some of the people that I'm involved with in Agoric were early people at Xanadu going back to the 1980s. And so I have sort of deep roots and attachment to a lot of these folks, which is, on the one hand, it's really great because we can trust each other, utterly kind of know each other's habits of thought. It also means, you know, we're kind of a bunch of OG guys sitting around saying, okay, you kids get off my lawn. So Agoric is a blockchain company doing smart contracting. Another place that I spent many years at was something called American Information Exchange, which was one of the first e-commerce companies doing person-to-person
在不同的初创公司和企业中从事各种工作。这可以说是其中的最新体现。我在Agoric合作的一些人是早在20世纪80年代Xanadu的早期成员。因此，我对这群人有着深厚的根源和情感连接，一方面，这真的很棒，因为我们可以完全信任彼此，可以说了解彼此的思维习惯。这也意味着，你知道，我们是一群坐在那里的老派（OG）家伙，心想：“行了，你们这些小屁孩别在我的草坪上撒野。”因此，Agoric是一家从事智能合约的区块链公司。我度过多年时光的另一个地方叫做美国信息交易所（American Information Exchange），它是最早开展个人对个人业务的电子商务公司之一。
commerce for the first time. And sort of the more modern manifestations of that would be things like PayPal or eBay. And Agoric is sort of the latest evolution of that doing what are called smart contracts, which are contract-like arrangements between parties, which are enforced by a computational system in the middle. And we're using the blockchain so that you don't have to have a trusted third party. The third party is more of an emergent phenomenon. We're kind of a peculiar blockchain company in that we're not really cryptocurrency maximalists. We're more, here's this useful technology for dealing with some fundamental
首次涉足商业领域。而这更现代的表现形式就是像PayPal或eBay这样的东西。Agoric可以说是它的最新演变，做的是所谓的智能合约，这是各方之间类似合约的安排，由中间的计算系统强制执行。我们正在使用区块链，这样你就不需要一个受信任的第三方。第三方更像是一种新兴现象。我们是一家奇特的区块链公司，因为我们并不是真正的加密货币极端主义者。我们更倾向于：这里有一个有用的技术，用于解决一些根本性的
security and trust problems. There's a lot of really interesting distributed system stuff in doing that. The particular piece that I work on is the kernel that underlies distributed computation framework, which we use. And the whole idea there is to provide a trustworthy computation environment. And that involves some really interesting, I don't want to say breakthroughs in security technology, because it's really technology that's been around since the 1970s. but the use of some techniques for achieving security, which are kind of cutting against the grain of the mainstream of thought in computer security. I kind of, when I'm feeling grumpy, kind of liken it to the state of computer security is kind of a mess right now. You think if we were learning things that systems would be getting more secure over time, and the history of medicine in the 19th century, where we're just starting to understand the germ theory of disease. And there were a few kind of lone voices in the
安全和信任问题。其中有很多非常有趣的分布式系统相关的东西。我负责的具体部分是底层分布式计算框架的核心，我们使用它。这里的整个想法是提供一个值得信赖的计算环境。这涉及到一些非常有趣的事情，我不想说这是安全技术上的突破，因为这实际上是自20世纪70年代以来就存在的技术。但是使用了一些实现安全的技术，这有点逆主流计算机安全思想的潮流。当我感到暴躁时，我有点把它比作当前计算机安全状况的一团糟。你以为如果我们一直在吸取教训，系统应该会随着时间的推移变得越来越安全，这就像19世纪的医学史，当时我们才刚刚开始理解疾病的细菌理论。当时有几个孤独的声音在
wilderness who were saying, hey, doctors, you know, wash your hands. And all the doctors were like, what? That's gonna make the miasma fall off. Yeah, or whatever. But basically, I think there is something similar to that, which is sort of the dominant paradigm in a lot of computer security infrastructures is what you call identity-based access control or ACLs, which is access control lists, where the fundamental security operation is to ask, well, who are you? And then based on who you are, we make a decision about whether we let you do or not do a particular thing. And this turns out to be a fatally flawed basis for building secure systems. So our system is built on something called object capabilities,
荒野中说：“嘿，医生们，你知道的，洗洗手吧。”而所有的医生都觉得：“什么？那会让瘴气掉下来的。”是的，诸如此类。但基本上，我认为有一个类似于这种情况的现象，即许多计算机安全基础设施中的主导范式被称为基于身份的访问控制或ACL，即访问控制列表，其中基本的安全操作是询问：“好吧，你是谁？”然后根据你是谁，我们决定是否允许你做或不做某件事。事实证明，这是构建安全系统的一个存在致命缺陷的基础。所以我们的系统建立在一种叫做对象能力（object capabilities）的东西之上，
which is much more oriented towards the question of, well, what can you do? And what authorities do you possess? What powers do you have in hand that allow you to do things? And this enables us to build secure distributed systems that are much more resistant to a lot of the traditional kinds of attacks that these systems tend to be subject to. There's another thing I've written about at greater length on my blog. So I'm trying to wrap my head around this. So usually you would have a list of users. These could be employees at your company or what have you. And then you have a list of groups. And so the permissions are on the group. And so if I want to get on the development cluster, I need to be in the development, you know, engineers group, right? And so, but it's all, you know, at the end of the day,
它更多地倾向于这样一个问题：“好吧，你能做什么？你拥有什么权限？你手头有什么权力可以让你做事情？”这使我们能够构建安全的分布式系统，这些系统对这些系统往往容易遭受的许多传统类型的攻击具有更强的抵抗力。关于这一点，我在我的博客上有更详细的撰写。所以我正在努力理解这一点。通常情况下，你会有一个用户列表。这些可能是你公司的员工或其他什么人。然后你会有一个群组列表。因此权限是分配给群组的。因此，如果我想加入开发集群，我需要加入开发，你知道的，工程师群组，对吧？所以，但这一切，你知道的，归根结底，
it's all like a MySQL database somewhere that just has a list of people and the groups they're in, right? And so what is what you're doing different? Yeah, so if you, sort of the classic model is what they call an access matrix, where you have a set of parties or people or things, and then a set of resources that you want to have access to, where the
它就像某个地方的MySQL数据库，里面只有一份人员名单以及他们所在的群组，对吧？那么你们所做的事有什么不同呢？是的，如果你，经典模型被称为访问矩阵（access matrix），其中你有一组参与者、人或事物，然后是一组你想要访问的资源，其中
resources could be files or they could be computer logins or whatever. And the question is, which of these is sort of the primary entity for managing this? And the access control list model is that you associate permissions with users. The capability model is that the resources themselves are the thing that are really important. So one way to think about this is think about, so you're editing a document in Microsoft Word, let's say, and you hit the save button and it goes to write your file out. And it asks the question, well, does this user have the authority to write to this file? And it does because it's your file and you have permission to the file and everything works. But at the same time, you have the authority to write to all of the other files that are on your
资源可以是文件、计算机登录名或其他任何东西。问题是，哪一个是用于管理这些资源的主要实体？访问控制列表模型是将权限与用户关联。而能力模型则是资源本身才是真正重要的东西。所以思考这个问题的一种方法是，假设你正在Microsoft Word中编辑一个文档，比方说，你点击保存按钮，它就会把你的文件写出来。然后它会问这样一个问题：“好吧，这个用户是否有权限写入这个文件？”答案是有的，因为这是你的文件，你拥有该文件的权限，一切都很顺利。但与此同时，你也有权限写入你系统上的所有其他
system. And this program that you're running could just as well take your file and ship it off to a server run by the mafia in Macedonia and send all of your secrets away and you wouldn't know the difference. And so the question is, why does this piece of software that you're running, and it could be Microsoft Word or it could be the Solitaire program, have the authority to sell all your secrets on the internet to the highest bidder. Because it does. The reason you mostly don't worry about that is because if Microsoft Word did that, like Microsoft would get sued. But in fact, what you're really running when you're interacting with some piece of software is you're interacting with an entire stack of stuff.
文件。而你正在运行的这个程序完全可以把你的文件拿走，发送给黑手党在马其顿运营的一台服务器，把你的所有机密都发走，而你却毫不知情。所以问题是，为什么你正在运行的这款软件——它可以是Microsoft Word，也可以是纸牌（Solitaire）程序——拥有在互联网上将你的所有机密以最高出价出售的权限？因为它确实有。你大多不担心这一点的原因是，如果Microsoft Word真的那样做了，微软就会被告上法庭。但事实上，当你与某些软件进行交互时，你正在与之交互的是一整堆东西。
So you're browsing the web. you've got the web browser, you've got the page that's loaded. You've got that page is filled with a bunch of JavaScript that came from, you know, a hundred different providers in different NPM packages. You've got the, the, the operating system that you're running. You've got the server that you're talking to, and it's composed of a bunch of components that came from a jillion different sources.
所以你在浏览网页。你有网页浏览器，有加载的页面。那个页面充满了来自，你知道的，来自不同NPM包的一百个不同提供商的各种JavaScript代码。你有正在运行的操作系统。你有与之通信的服务器，它由来自无数不同来源的大量组件组成。
And are you really want to say that every single one of those components has the authority to act as you? You know, that seems like a very sketchy foundation for... Yeah, but you see this all the time with these like poison pill versions of software where there's like uh you know there's a a library that just draws charts and so you have a website and you know you have this chart library and then someone releases a poisoned version where when your web server loads that version of the chart library,
难道你真的想说，每一个单独的组件都拥有以你的身份行事的权限吗？你知道，这听起来是一个非常可疑的基础……是的，但你经常在这些毒丸（poison pill）版本的软件中看到这种情况，比如有一个库只是用来绘制图表，所以你有一个网站，你知道，你有这个图表库，然后有人发布了一个带毒的版本，当你的web服务器加载那个版本的图表库时，
it actually dumps all your passwords out. Well, there have been a number of supply chain attacks, particularly through sketchy NPM packages, where there was quite a notorious thing a few years back where somebody managed to take over maintenance of some some minor package that was being used for some purpose but it didn't require a lot of maintenance and suddenly volunteered to take it over from the the person who had had created it who was happy to give it give the the chore to somebody else uh and they inserted a bunch of stuff that would sort of troll through your system to see if you were using a particular cryptocurrency wallet. And if it did, if it found that stuff, it would then take your various credentials and ship them off and allow somebody to get into your crypto wallet
它实际上把你的所有密码都倾倒出来了。嗯，确实发生过多次供应链攻击，特别是通过可疑的NPM包，几年前发生过一件相当臭名昭著的事，当时有人设法接管了某个用于某种目的但不需要太多维护的小型包的维护工作，它不需要太多维护，然后突然自愿从原作者那里接管过来，原作者很高兴把这个杂务交给别人，然后他们插入了一堆代码，会在你的系统中四处搜寻，看看你是否在使用某个特定的加密钱包。如果是的话，如果找到了那些东西，它就会拿走你的各种凭证并把它们发出去，让别人能够进入你的加密钱包，
and steal all your Bitcoin. These kinds of supply chain attacks are increasingly of concern. And in a sanely constructed computational environment, these things would just not be possible because it wouldn't matter what code you loaded because that code wouldn't have the authority to get at this stuff in the first place. And therefore, it didn't matter how malicious it was. It literally does not have the authority. It does not it was it literally does not have the authority it does not have access it does not have the capability to get to the things that you were you were profiling to prevent it from getting to because i mean it sounds it sounds like snap uh snapcraft or docker these kind of things i mean not not literally but it sounds like uh spiritually
并偷走你所有的比特币。这类供应链攻击越来越令人担忧。在一个构建健康的计算环境中，这些事情根本是不可能的，因为你加载的是什么代码根本不重要，因为该代码一开始就没有权限接触到这些东西。因此，它有多恶意也无所谓。它字面意义上就没有权限。它字面意义上没有权限，没有访问权限，没有能力到达你试图阻止它到达的东西，因为我的意思是，这听起来像Snapcraft或Docker这类东西，我的意思是，不是字面上的，但在精神上
similar where like uh you know, in Snapcraft, you actually say, you know, this package, this Unix package will only run a server on TCP port, you know, 2048. And so, you know, if it tries to run a server somewhere else for some hacker to go and get all of your data, Snapcraft just won't allow it. And same thing with Docker.
很相似，就像，你知道，在Snapcraft中，你实际上会说，你知道，这个包，这个Unix包将只在TCP端口，你知道，2048上运行一个服务器。所以，你知道，如果它试图在其他地方运行一个服务器供黑客去获取你所有的所有数据，Snapcraft根本不允许这样做。Docker也是如此。
You have to forward ports and everything. Right, and this is sort of a much more, the whole object capability approach is much more sort of structured and disciplined way of doing that. The model is in a good memory-safe object-oriented programming language. And ironically, we're using JavaScript,
你必须转发端口等等。没错，这是一种更加、整个对象能力方法是一种更有结构、更有纪律的做事方式。该模型采用一种良好的内存安全面向对象编程语言。具有讽刺意味的是，我们使用的是JavaScript，
which for weird accidents of history, it turns out, although many, many of the things which are JavaScript is notorious for being basically a sieve with respect to security, with being infinitely malleable, sort of infinitely malleable properties, meaning it's almost impossible to securealleable properties meaning is almost impossible to to secure regular javascript out of the box but in fact there goes our chance to have brave
由于历史上的怪异巧合，事实证明，尽管JavaScript在安全方面臭名昭著，基本上就是一个筛子，具有无限可塑的属性，也就是说几乎不可能保护常规JavaScript的安全。但是，这就毁了我们请Brave作为本节目赞助商的机会，我不太清楚他们的具体关系是什么，但Brendan Eich是我们公司的顾问。好极了，Brave的粉丝们，Brave一直是我们的坚决支持者。好吧，不开玩笑了。我的意思是，实际上，如果Brendan能来节目里就太好了。由于历史原因，JavaScript被证明是地球上几乎所有其他编程语言中唯一可能被确保安全的语言。你实际上可以从JavaScript中划分出一个可以确保安全的安全子集，其安全属性可以以可靠的方式自动强制执行，这种方式允许模块生态系统中的绝大多数、绝大多数现有的软件和工具在无需修改的情况下继续开箱即用，前提是它没有做任何恶意的事情。你实际上可以
as a sponsor for this show is a is a is i'm not sure what they quite but the relationship is but brendan eich is an advisor to our company uh nice fans of brave Fans of Brave, and Brave, they've been big supporters of ours. Yeah, no, I'm kidding. I mean, actually, it would be great if Brandon could come on the show. JavaScript, for historical reasons, turns out to be, unlike almost every other programming language on the planet, sort of uniquely possible to secure. You can actually carve out a securable subset of JavaScript, which can be, whose security properties can be automatically enforced in a reliable way, in a way that allows the vast, vast, vast majority of the existing software and tooling in the module ecosystem to continue to run out of the box without modification, assuming it's not doing anything malicious. And you can actually
用JavaScript构建一个安全的编程环境，这与地球上几乎所有其他编程语言都不同。由于JavaScript实际上是可确保安全的（它本身并不安全，但它是可确保安全的），我们构建了一个它的安全版本，我们称之为硬化JavaScript（hardened JavaScript），它强制执行了构建安全系统所需的所有对象能力安全属性，而这正是我们用于智能合约平台的代码。哇，太酷了，那个硬化JavaScript是一个开源项目吗？还是说所有东西都是开源的？我们的目标是最终将使JavaScript硬化的各种东西
build a secure programming environment out of JavaScript, which is different from almost every other programming language on the planet. And because JavaScript is in fact securable, it's not secure in and of itself, but it is securable, we have built a secure version of that, which we call hardened JavaScript, which enforces all of the object capability security properties, which are necessary to actually build secure systems and and this is what we're using for our smart contracting platform wow cool is that um hardened javascript like an open source project or is that everything is all open source and our objective in is is to eventually have all of the various things which make Javascript hardened
最终进入官方的ECMAScript语言标准中。我们一直非常活跃，我们和我们的创始人们以及Agoric的各种人员，早在Agoric成立之前很久就开始了，一直非常活跃地参与TC39委员会，将这些使JavaScript可确保安全的要素以及实际确保安全的工具
eventually make their way into the official ECMAScript language standard. And we've been very active, we and our founders and various people in Agoric, starting from long before Agoric was founded, have been very active in the TC39 committee, getting these things which make JavaScript securable and then the tools to actually secure things
逐步纳入标准中。虽然还有一些部分需要完成，但我们在那方面取得了非常好的进展。我认为前景相当不错。我们最终将能够创建安全的、分区的、面向对象的程序。哇，非常酷。那么，稍微谈谈Agoric作为一家公司，有什么独特之处
incrementally incorporated into the standard. And there's still a few pieces to go, but we have made very good progress on that. And I think the prognosis is quite good. We will eventually be able to create secure compartmented object-oriented programs. Wow, very cool. So jumping to GORIC a little bit as a company, what is something kind of unique
关于……嗯，事实上，在此之前，Agoric在招人吗？我知道现在经济形势很奇特，所以我大概应该提前问一下。是的，我们确实在招人。我不确定在资本化方面我被允许说些什么，但我们的资金在一段时间内是充裕的，我们处于发展轨道上，我们正在招人。我们需要一些工程人才。我们需要一些产品营销和支持人员。如果你访问我们的网站 agoric.com，上面有一个关于“招贤纳士”（careers）的链接，它会告诉你我们目前有哪些职位空缺。明白了。
about... Well, actually, before we do that, is Agoric hiring? I know that it's a strange economic time, so I probably should ask that in advance. Yes, we are hiring, actually. I'm not sure what I'm allowed to say in terms of how capitalized we are, but we're comfortable for a while, and we're on a growth path, and we are hiring. We need some engineering people. We need some product marketing and support people. If you go to our website, agoric.com, there is a link for careers and it will tell you what openings we currently have. Got it.
有实习岗位吗？我们有很多还在上学的朋友。我不知道。好吧，我们会去查查看。我们会看看能否把它加入到节目备注中。在Agoric工作的一大独特之处是什么？可能是每个人都在周二打乒乓球。有什么让Agoric与众不同？哇，这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为它非常不同，除了它是我认为公司本来应该有的正常方式之外。只是我工作过的绝大多数不是我联合创立的公司都没有这种品质。
Are there intern positions? We have a lot of folks who are still kind of in the middle of school. I do not know. Okay, we'll look that up. We'll see if we can add it to the show notes. What is one kind of unique thing about working at Agoric? It could be everyone plays ping pong on Tuesdays. What is something that makes Agoric kind of different? Wow, that's a really interesting question because it is very different, except that it's what I think of as the normal way companies should be. It's just that very few of the companies that I've worked for that I haven't been one of the founders of have had the quality.
有很多……当我面试工程职位的人时，我寻找的品质是某种程度的——我不知道你想不想称之为投入度，或者那种感觉，即那里有一个你可以与之交谈的人，可以就深奥的事情进行对话，那些真正将解决这些难题视为他们核心本质一部分的人。他们只是对学习事物和弄清楚如何做事感兴趣。是的，这很有意义。
There's a lot of people who are... When I've been interviewing people for engineering positions, the quality that I look for, which is a degree of, I don't know if you want to call it engagement, or the sense that there's a person there that you can talk to and have conversations about deep things and people who are actually sort of, it is sort of part of the core essence of their being that they're interested in solving these hard problems. And they're just interested in learning about stuff and figuring out how to do stuff. Yeah, that makes sense.
有一种现象，我们的另一位创始人曾经在太平洋西北地区的一家大公司工作过，我们暂且这么说吧。好的。我想我已经把它缩小到两家了，但请继续。被称为“有工作的聪明人”，他在那里遇到了非常聪明、作为工程师完全胜任且有能力、知识渊博的人，但这只是他们的工作。这就是他们做的事情。他们做得很好，但这并不是定义他们存在的东西。我们有很多人的工作触及了他们是谁的核心。这意味着很多人对事物是如何运作的非常感兴趣，
There's a phenomenon that one of our other founders who used to work for a big company in the Pacific Northwest, let's just say. Okay. I think I've narrowed it down to two, but go ahead. Referred to as smart guys with a job where he encountered people who are perfectly intelligent, perfectly competent and capable as engineers, knowledgeable, but this is their job. This is the thing that they did. They do it fine, but it's kind of not what defines their being. We have a lot of people who, this goes to the core of who they are. A lot of that means that people are very interested in how stuff works,
对解决问题感兴趣，并且仅仅因为他们能做到就去参与困难的技术问题。是的。你是如何筛选出这种特质的？我的意思是，有时当你在面试中与某人交谈时，你可以隐约察觉到这一点。但有没有一种系统的方法可以筛选出这种特质？这很难。我认为这是可能的，因为我是一家初创公司的创始人，这是我们寻找的一种品质，但我没有神奇的公式。部分原因在于“我一眼就能认出来”，不过其实也不是，因为我知道我曾雇用过一些人，结果发现他们并不具备这种品质。嗯，可能是这样，我们不知道基准线是什么。
in solving problems, and engaging with difficult technical problems just because they can. Yeah. How do you select for that? I mean, sometimes when you're talking to somebody in an interview, you can kind of pick up on that. But is there a systematic way that you can select for that? It's hard. I think it's possible because I've been the founder of a number of startups and this is a quality we look for, but I don't have a magic formula. Part of it is I know it when I see it, except that I don't really, because I know I've kind of hired people and it turns out that they didn't have this quality. Well, it might be, we don't know what the baseline is.
比如你们的转化率（yield）可能高于平均水平。它不会是100%。这倒也是。我认为正如我所说，存在这种投入度的品质，当你把一个问题放在某人面前时，他们会对它感兴趣，就其本身而言。
Like your yield might be higher than average. It's not going to be 100%. That is true. I think there is this, as I say, this quality of engagement where you put a problem in front of somebody and they're interested in it, sort of in and of itself.
有一种人会思考未来，思考这个事物存在会对世界产生什么影响。人们在可视化事物如果有所不同会是怎样的时候遇到困难，这让我感到非常惊讶。如果你向世界引入某种以前不存在的能力，事情会如何改变？这倒不是说人们一定能给出正确的答案，而是说这是一个有趣的问题。他们喜欢思考这个问题。不仅是因为他们喜欢思考这个问题，而是他们无法不去思考
There is the kind of person who thinks about the future, thinks about what would the consequences of this thing existing be on the world. It's really quite astonishing to me the degree to which people have difficulty visualizing how something would be if it were different. If you were to introduce some capability to the world that wasn't there before, how would things change? And it's not so much that people necessarily get the right answer, but that that's an interesting problem. And they like thinking about that. And not just that they like like thinking about that but they can't not think about
这个问题。是的，我注意到的有一件事是——顺便呼应你的观点——在某些，我从未在太平洋西北地区工作过，但我曾在北加州工作过，嗯，是的，我认为你所指的其实是一种能动性（agency），或者至少这是其中一部分，那种感觉，你知道，“看，如果我实现了这个东西，那将会带来一些改变”，而不是像“老板给我代码写，我为老板写代码，然后系统就在不断向前推进”。我觉得我看到很多的一种现象是，经常阅读科幻小说的人，它让他们习惯于思考如果发生不同的事情，未来会是什么样。
about that yeah one thing i noticed is is uh to your point at some of the i've never been working i've never worked in the pacific northwest but i've worked in northern california and um yeah i think what what you're getting at is like a sense of agency or at least that's part of it is a sense that like you know look if i if i implement this thing that's going to cause some change versus like you know boss gives me code to write i write code for boss and then the system is just rolling forward there's there's like i think like one of the things i see a lot is people who read a lot of science fiction it conditions them to think about how the future could be if different things happen.
早在Xanadu的早期，我花了很多时间在全国各地旅行，做关于超文本的演讲。没有人知道这是什么。我得到的反馈总体上非常积极。但随后人们会问一些奇怪的问题，比如：“你为什么要把文档放到网上？谁会花钱制作所有这些超链接？”对的，对的。这些问题简直就是：“什么？”任何在万维网（World Wide Web）上花过五分钟的人都不会想到去问
When back in the early days of Xanadu, I spent a lot of time traveling around the country giving presentations about hypertext. Nobody had any idea what this was. The reception I get was generally very positive. But then people would ask weird questions like, why would you want to put documents online? Who's going to pay to make all of these hyperlinks? Right, right. Which are just like, what? And no one who has spent five minutes with the World Wide Web would ever think to ask
这些问题，因为很明显，事情根本就不是那样运作的。人们很难想象，如果我指尖拥有全世界的知识，那意味着什么？这甚至不一定意味着他们——正如我所说——知道那意味着什么，而是这显然是一件重要且具变革性的事情，如果它发生了的话。为了真正强调这一点，你知道，我通过用神经网络玩围棋获得了博士学位
those questions because obviously that's just not and not how things would work. And people would have difficulty visualizing, if I had all of the world's knowledge at my fingertips, what would that mean? And it's not even necessarily that they, as I say, that they know what that would mean, but that that is clearly an important and transformative thing if it were to happen. That's really, just like double down on that, you know, I got my PhD in playing Go
，你知道，事后看来，这就像是，好吧，神经网络显然是正确的答案。但我记得，你知道，我记得，你知道，像我父母和其他人说的那样，“谁真正在乎你围棋下得有多好？我甚至不玩围棋，作为一个人类。”所以，但我——但——但回到你的观点，这就像我能感觉到这个游戏有某种强大的力量，它与国际象棋和其他这些游戏非常相似，但它完全是极其复杂的。如果你能攻克它，这里面蕴含着某种强大的力量。部分原因仅仅是，就像，你知道，草稿，就像草稿并不快。它真的不够敏捷。它无法隐藏，但它能够触及
with neural networks, which, you know, like in hindsight, it's like, okay, neural networks clearly were the right answer there. But I remember, you know, I remember, you know, like my parents, other people saying like saying like like who really cares if you play really good go like i don't even play go right as a human so but i but but to your point it's like i could just feel that there was something powerful about this game that is so similar to chess these other games but it's just completely intractable. And if you could crack that, it was, there's something powerful there. And part of it is just, it's like, you know, the draft, like a draft is not fast. It's not really agile. It can't hide, but it can reach
别人无法触及的果实。因此，它在生态系统中赢得了它的位置。所以围棋就像是这种高高在上的果实，我只是觉得能够攻克它有一种强大的力量。就像，正如你所说，我不能告诉你“是的，我们将把围棋变成能够在广告网站上向某人兜售丰田汽车的东西”——我做不到这一点，但我只是知道那里有些东西，对吧？嗯，当国际象棋被计算攻克时——我们可以这样说——很多年前，这给我留下了深刻的印象，有很多国际象棋界的人觉得，“好吧，就是这样。你知道，国际象棋结束了。”
that fruit that no one else can reach. And so that earns it its place or an ecosystem and so like go is like this really high up kind of fruit and i just felt like there was something powerful about being able to crack that and it's just like to your point like you can't i can't tell you yes we're going to turn go into being able to sell someone like a toyota on on an ads website like i couldn't do that but i just knew that there was like something there, right? Well, one of the things that really struck me when chess kind of fell to computation, let us say, many years ago, there were a lot of chess people who were kind of like, well, that's it. You know, chess is over.
“它完成了。这是一个已解决的问题。多么令人沮丧。”而当他们攻克围棋时，反应更像是：“哦，这真的很有趣。”所有的围棋爱好者都说：“哦，这揭示了一个我们以前从未看过的全新探索空间。哇，这真的很有趣。”他们不认为自己被取代了，而是认为一个全新的可能性空间为他们打开了。我认为其中的不同反应很有趣。我真的
It's done. It's a solved problem. How depressing. And when they kind of cracked Go, the reaction was much more like, oh, this is really interesting. And there were all of these Go enthusiasts who said, oh, this has revealed an entire new space of exploration that we hadn't looked at before. Wow, this is really interesting. And they kind of saw this not as they had been displaced, but rather that a whole new space of possibilities had been opened up for them. And I think that the disparate reactions there are interesting. I'm not really
不确定这意味着什么，但技术确实具有赋能作用。我并不是一个技术决定论者，但我非常清楚，推动人类文明进步的很大一部分最有效的方法，就是扩大我们可用的技术调色板。我对那些反对这种做法的特定类型的人感到非常沮丧。就像，“哦，不，不，不，技术是我们所有问题的根源。”这就像，“嗯，是的，但是……”好吧，这就像“哦，不，不，不，技术是我们所有问题的根源”，而这就好像，“嗯，是的，但是……”好吧，它两者皆是，它既是我们所有问题的根源，也是我们所有解决方案的根源——或者至少占了很大比例，对吧？就像……你知道，如果我们没有技术，我可以坐在这里拿着这瓶纯净水，以及我通过庞大供应链获得的食物，然后感到快乐，你知道。酷，所以这太棒了。我想，你知道，大家一定要去了解一下Agoric
sure what it means, but there's definitely something about technologies that are enabling. I'm not really a technology determinist, but it's very clear to me that much of what has propelled the advancement of human civilization the most effective ways you can do that is by expanding the technology palette that we have to work from. And I get very frustrated with a certain kind of person who pushes against that. It's like, oh, no, no, no, technology is the source of all of our problems. And it's like, well, yeah, but. Well, it's like oh no no no technology is the source of all of our problems and it's like well yeah but well it's it's both it's the it's the source of all of our problems and the source of all of all of our solutions or at least a large percentage of them right it's like uh you know if we didn't have technology i could sit here with this uh you know purified water and this uh food that i got for first enormous supply chain and just be happy you know cool so this this is amazing i think uh you know definitely folks check out check out agoric
如果你……实际上，在工程方面，Agoric在寻找什么样的技能？是前端，后端？是C，JavaScript？主要是JavaScript，虽然我认为我们寻找的根本东西是：你能不能自己写代码解决问题？好吧。也就是，这是一个过度专业化的问题，特别是在编程语言方面，有人会说，“嗯，我是C++程序员，或者我是JavaScript程序员，
if you uh actually so what background on the engineering side what sort of uh skills uh is agoric looking for is it is front-end, back-end? Is it C, JavaScript? It's mostly JavaScript, although I think the fundamental thing we look for is, can you program your way out of a paper bag? All right. Which is, and this is something that's a sort of over-specialization, particularly in programming languages, where somebody says, well, I'm a C++ programmer, or I'm a JavaScript programmer,
或者我是前端人员，诸如此类。”我认为更根本的问题是：你能解决问题吗？因为在这个行业里，每星期都有新的编程语言。如果今天是JavaScript，明天可能是Rust，或者后星期可能是你从未听说过的甚至还没被创造出来的新语言。所以那些长期从事这项工作的人，你知道，通常已经接受了这样的观点：我有一套新工具，我将用它来完成这个新工作。我将把这项工作的第一部分花在学习使用这些工具上。因此，我需要能够做的是掌握这套新工具，
or I'm a front-end person or whatever. And I think the more fundamental question is, can you solve problems? Because in this industry, it's programming language of the week. And if it's JavaScript today, it might be Rust tomorrow or it might be something else that you've never even heard of that hasn't even been created yet the week after that. And so people have been doing this for a long time, you know, often, you know, have adopted the perspective of I've got a new set of tools that I'm going to use to do this new job. And I'm going to spend the first part of this job learning to use those tools. And so what I need to be able to do is to acquire this new tool set
而不是“嗯，我知道如何使用这一个东西，我要把自己包装成一个精通这一个东西的专家”。是的，这很有意义。是的，完全如此。太酷了。所以，如果这听起来让你很兴奋，如果你对硬化JavaScript、从事这类基于区块链的安全协议感兴趣，去看看Agoric，了解他们的产品，也去看看他们的招贤纳士页面，看看那里有什么机会。Agoric的愿景之一是
as opposed to, well, I know how to use this one thing and I'm going to market myself as a person who's an expert at using this one thing. Yep, that makes sense. Yeah, totally. So cool. So yeah, so if this sounds exciting to you, if hardening JavaScript, working on these sort of, you know, kind of blockchain based security protocols, check out Agoric, check out the product that they have and also check out the careers page and and and see sort of what opportunities are there. One of the visions with the GORIC is
我们致力于——我们讨论了智能合约——但实际上它的核心是降低分散各方之间合作的成本和风险。我们的愿景是，如果我们能降低成本，
we're all about, we talked about smart contracts, but really what's about is lowering the costs and risks of cooperation among dispersed parties. The vision is that if we can lower the cost,
降低合作的风险，我们将拥有一个更加合作的世界。一个更加合作的世界会是一个更好的地方。酷。是的，这很有意义。这是结束节目的完美方式。我想如果大家想联系你，芯片，他们可以在Twitter上找到你，地址是 @E-P-O-P-T。
lower the risk of cooperation, we get a more cooperative world. A more cooperative world would be a better place. Cool. Yeah, that makes sense. That's a perfect way to end the show. So I think if folks want to reach you, Chip, they can reach you on Twitter. It's at E-P-O-P-T.
我们会把它放在节目备注中。还有 habitatchronicles.com。我们也会把它放在节目备注中。如果你在收听的朋友们，如果你在使用Podcast Addict或任何这些播客应用，我已经开始将节目备注直接放在RSS源中了。所以你总是可以访问 programmingthrowdown.com，但你也可以直接从大多数这些播客应用中获取所有这些链接。如果你的应用没有，请告诉我，我们可以解决这个问题。所以感谢大家在Patreon和通过Audible订阅对我们的支持。我们非常感激。谢谢你，Chip，来到节目中。这真的非常迷人。我们探讨了一系列不同的事情。
We'll put that in the show notes. There's also habitatchronicles.com. We'll also put that in the show notes. And if you're using folks out there, if you're using Podcast Addict or any of these podcast things, I've started putting the show notes right there in the RSS feed as well. So you could always go to programmingthrowdown.com, but you'll also be able to get all of these links straight from most of these podcast apps. And if your app doesn't have it, let me know and we can work on that. So thanks everyone for supporting us on Patreon and through Audible subscriptions. We really appreciate that. And thank you, Chip, for coming on the show. It's been really fascinating. We ran through a gambit of different things.
你知道，最后的一件事——我把最后发言权留给你，但我注意到的最后一件事是，你的背景是如此多元，从，你知道，你从事了如此多不同的事情。我希望这能真正引起人们的共鸣。你知道，我想最近有人问我，“你知道，我是否——我会不会有点像——我会不会感到紧张？”因为，坦白说，我40岁了。我想这就是所谓的“过了巅峰期”吧。我不知道你怎么称呼40岁，但我今年40岁了。所以我说：“你会不会担心，你知道，你无法继续当工程师？”我说：“不，我不会担心，
You know, one of the last things, I'll let you have the last word, but one of the last things that I've noticed is just how diverse your background has been from, you know, you worked on so many different things. And I want that to really resonate with people. You know, I think that somebody recently asked me, you know, do I, am I going to sort of like, am I nervous? Because, you know, full disclosure, I'm 40 years old. I guess that's what over the hill. I don't know what you call 40, but I turned 40 this year. And so I said, are you worried that, you know, you won't be able to continue being an engineer? And I said, no, I said, you know, you won't be able to continue being an engineer?
我知道，你不会无法继续当工程师。”我说：“不，我要当工程师，直到他们把——你知道——把我抬出去，而且我在此期间一直都很胜任。”而且，你知道，我认为这是因为，你知道，我一直在学习新东西，做不同的事情，并且参与各种各样的领域。这就是多年来从事工程技术的意义所在。所以我想，你知道，看看你的职业生涯，Chip，你也涉足了许多不同的领域，我认为这确实是人们应该带走的心得。是的。而且对于你刚才说的那个评论，
And I said, no, I said, I'm going to be an engineer until like they just, you know, carry me out feet first and I'm going to be competent the whole time. And, you know, I think it's because, you know, I'm constantly learning new things and doing different things and part of a variety of different areas. And that's what it means to do engineering for many years. And so I think, you know, looking at kind of your career, Chip, you've also kind of been in many different areas. And I think that's really something that people should take home. Yeah. And I think to the comment you just made,
我的意思是，我63岁了，我仍然有你刚刚描述的那种感觉。我有，年龄歧视在硅谷是一个真实存在的现象。我有一个风险投资家朋友，他将雇佣年长的工程师视为他的秘密武器之一。
I mean, I'm 63, and I still have the same sensation that you just described. I have a, age discrimination is a real thing in Silicon Valley. I have a venture capitalist friend who views hiring older engineers as one of his secret weapons.
太棒了。因为那些搞年龄歧视的人都很蠢。好吧，任何，是的。任何事情都会产生套利空间，对吧？是的。是的，我，我，我，我要一直做这件事，直到他们把我抬出去。希望，你知道，我们有一大群人，他们的立场是，你知道，“我们要么长生不老，要么在尝试中死去”。太棒了。
Nice. Because the people who engage in age discrimination are stupid. Well, any, yeah. Anything is going to create arbitrage, right? Yeah. Yeah. And I, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm going to be doing this until they carry me out feet first. And hopefully, you know, we have a whole cohort of folks who's, who's, you know, position is, is, you know, we're going to live forever or die trying. Nice.
而且，你知道，我们也在攻克这个问题。好吧。太酷了。太棒了。好的，Chip。非常感谢。我非常感激你能来到节目并抽出时间。太棒了。非常荣幸。谢谢。署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，进行演绎和改编，但您必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同的许可协议分享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And, you know, and we're working on that problem, too. All right. Cool. Great. All right, Chip. Thank you so much. I really appreciate you coming on the show and your time. Great. It's been a delight. Thanks. attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道的，我们也在解决这个问题。好了。太棒了。很好。好了，奇普（Chip）。非常感谢你。非常感谢你来参加这个节目并抽出时间。太棒了。这真是一次愉快的经历。谢谢。署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议 你可以自由共享、复制、分发、传输作品，改编作品，但你必须对我和帕特里克（Patrick）进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。